This is Jocko podcast number 76 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good evening.
Echo did evening.
Yeah,
freedom.
That's something that you hear me talk about
all the time.
And I say little things like don't take it for granted.
And I say be thankful for your freedom.
And I even say things like,
you don't appreciate your freedom until it's gone.
Pretty common statements you hear from people.
But how many of us
have actually had our freedom taken away
and not metaphorically speaking and not some self imposed and thereby self
controlled way
and not in some way trapped by a situation in our life that we don't have the
courage to get out of.
But I am talking about an actual
loss
of freedom.
Caged,
controlled,
starved,
beaten,
tortured.
How long can you take that form?
An hour.
A day.
What about a week or a month?
What about a year?
Yeah,
for six years.
What do you do?
How do you survive?
How do you get up every day and face the awful reality
that you live in
darkness.
Fear,
oppression.
And how do you take that darkness and that fear?
And that oppression and turn it into something good.
Well,
it is my honor today
to have with us a man that can answer those questions.
Retired Navy,
Captain Charles Charlie Plumb Naval Academy graduate F Four Phantom fighter
pilot
and prisoner of war.
Yeah,
written north Vietnam
for six years.
Six years.
Sir.
It is an absolute honor to have you on and thank you so much for being here.
Thank you jack.
Oh,
it's a pleasure to be with you.
And
let's just start from the beginning of Captain Charlie Plumb you were you,
I know you were born where?
I was actually born in Gary,
Indiana during World War II.
My father was about to be inducted and so he moved us to a little tiny town in
Kansas where he thought,
um,
my mother and I and my big sister could live there while he went off to war.
Well,
as it turned out,
he couldn't pass the physical so he didn't go to war.
But that's where I grew up in a tiny town in the middle,
Kansas.
And I know you,
uh,
you did,
you went to work pretty at a pretty early age throwing papers that you referred
to that in the book.
And I just,
not just in the stylistic thing,
isn't it frozen,
but no one throws papers anymore.
It doesn't happen.
There's no kids with paper roads anymore.
I guess that's true.
I read a statistic one time of all the,
of all the successful people in the world,
most of them were paper boys when they were kids,
but not anymore.
You know,
the,
you're right,
you don't see that now they're throwing up Twitter posts.
That's it.
No,
I flew I through the to peak a daily capital there and there's a little town of,
um,
300 people and I had about 55 customers.
The,
the route was five miles long.
And on a cold February morning in Kansas,
that was off the long way.
I finally convinced my father that I could,
that I could buy a motor scooter with all of my earnings.
And so we went across the river where there was no bank in town and went across
the river to Perry,
Kansas.
And,
uh,
borrowed enough money to buy a Cushman motor scooter and I was only 14 when that
happens.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I got arrested one night
driving my motor skirt up to no good.
You got arrested on a motor scooter?
Well,
I was trying to go to the county fair cause can you even speed a motor scooter?
Is that possible?
No,
no,
no.
But I was small for my age,
so at 14,
I,
I know I wasn't five feet and had my buddy on the back and he was even smaller
than I.
And I think that the cops just as these do look kids on a motor scooter in the
middle of the night and we were arrested and uh,
at some point,
I think it was a,
you had a,
a basketball coach.
There were coaching your school that was a pilot in World War II.
Yeah,
he was,
he was actually,
uh,
he,
he was a vet if it not a pilot.
He was a doughboy and world war one.
And he had shrapnel in his leg from his warning.
He walked with a limp and,
but then he was quite a disciplinarian and he,
he tried to make that a little basketball team work,
but we were just really not,
not very talented.
What is it about,
I don't know.
When I was a kid and I would see,
you know,
a Vietnam vet for me,
that's primarily what I would see his old Vietnam vets.
And I'd say,
Hey,
that guy's got shrapnel in his leg and walks with a limp.
When I grow up,
I want shrapnel in my leg and I want to walk with a limp.
That's my goal.
Is that just,
is that just part of Male,
you know,
boy in nature it may very well be so.
So what did he tell you about,
about pilots?
Did he explain that to you or how did you get the idea from,
you know,
being a doughboy to be in a pilot?
Well,
a quite a long transition.
See,
this was early on in my career and I had a coach later in high school that had
been a pilot in World War II.
Okay.
So a Bill Johnson had been a pilot and in fact,
uh,
he flew a,
a fas and off aircraft carriers and I was fascinated by that whole idea.
But I will tell you that being a hayseed from Kansas,
I never even dreamed of flying an airplane.
I,
I'd never been in one.
Uh,
I seen them fly over,
but the whole idea of ever even riding in an airplane,
let alone piloting one was,
was beyond my grasp.
It really was it.
So,
so how did you end up then transitioning from high school and you end up going
to the Naval Academy?
Well,
that was kind of by accident too.
Uh,
I needed an education.
My parents were too poor to send me to college.
I started looking for scholarships and um,
my,
my older sister was dating a guy who was an inner OTC,
a student at University of Kansas.
And he gave me a book that says,
Here's how you apply for the OTC and Kansas.
Well,
the back page of the book in fairly small letters said,
oh,
by the way,
it's the same qualifications to go to the Naval Academy.
Well,
what the heck?
Did you even know what the Naval Academy was or did you figure it out right
there?
I did not know.
I really had no idea.
I didn't know about the army navy game.
I didn't know anything.
Now my closest relative and the military was a cousin in the coast guard.
And so I was just,
I was just ignorant about the military a total.
So,
you know,
I like,
I like to see here Jocko and tell you that at all these great dreams,
you know,
and being a fighter pilot and the admiral and commanding ships and squadrons and
all.
But no,
it was all by accident.
In fact,
I,
when I applied,
well,
you know,
you get to appointments from Congressmen,
the Congressmen of my district in Kansas,
I did it by a competitive method and,
and everybody who was interested took,
uh,
a government test to,
for a g rating,
no government service rating the GS test.
And there were about 35 guys that took the test.
And so he nominated five of us who got better scores on the test and the rest.
And then he appointed one,
uh,
one guy to the naval academy and an alternate and I was the second alternate.
Okay.
Well the first guy also had an appointment to,
to,
uh,
the air force academy.
So he took that,
the second guy discovered girls.
Oh yeah.
So I was actually the second alternate they go.
And so I got on that Greyhound bus in Kansas City,
Kansas.
And the two days later,
it took me two days to get to,
uh,
to Washington DC.
And of course I was seeing country I'd never seen before.
Um,
and that's when I raise my hand as you did and pledge to defend the constitution
of the United States against all enemies foreign and domestic.
And then at some point it at the Athenaeum.
Did you,
did you know about naval aviation,
I guess you did,
from,
uh,
from Bob Johnson,
he told you about naval aviation.
Did you have that thought in your mind of naval aviation at that point?
Not really.
I still,
uh,
I still kind of assumed that I could never qualify to do that,
you know,
and,
and thinking back at it,
you know,
I think,
well,
where were my dreams?
But,
um,
kids that grow up in little towns don't usually have big dreams.
We don't know how to do that.
And my parents,
my father had completed the eighth grade and that was his education.
My mother had in fact completed high school,
but I was one of the first and the family to ever go to college.
And so,
um,
you know,
it was,
I,
it wasn't even,
it wasn't even a thought part of the thought process.
So,
uh,
once I got to the Naval Academy and you know,
thought back to Bob Johnson and,
uh,
and,
and that kind of experience and saw that there was a possibility of doing this,
then my energies and efforts to turn that towards a naval aviation.
And it must have been,
I mean that's always been ultra competitive after you cademy and I know we had
another pilot on Dave Burke
and he was talking about how each step of the way he kind of looked around and
said,
I think I can actually do this.
You know,
it's kind of the same thing.
You look around and say,
I think I can get the best grades or I think I can get you this position.
At some point you must have said,
I think I can.
I think I can do this.
There was,
as a matter of fact and is a great revelation,
you know,
when you're convenient,
finally talk to yourself into accepting the fact that you do have the talent to
do this.
Um,
and until that point you,
you don't really try as hard I guess.
And while you're at the academy,
also you,
is this when you got involved with an for the first time,
is that at the,
at the Naval Academy and was my high school sweetheart.
Oh yeah.
We played the French horn in the band together.
Those girls with the French orange.
Yeah.
Yeah,
she was a,
she is a beauty in and a,
it was a beauty and she showed up at our school,
but was,
um,
she,
she came,
she came into our little town in Kansas from Indiana and she had a boyfriend and
Indiana.
She wasn't telling me about,
you know,
for the first several,
we don't care about that boyfriend.
And His name is Bart.
And then they called them black bart.
So Bart was,
um,
and,
and she wouldn't kiss me,
you know,
I mean,
we dated for months and it's the girl wouldn't kiss me.
Yeah.
Dang.
You know what I mean?
It's tough.
I mean,
I mean it's the most reaction I've ever seen.
Got Acrobat or whatever the podcast.
I think he's been there a bad memories on that.
Tobacco flashback her heart.
Maybe we should talk about your stories,
all kinds of kissing denials.
So,
uh,
finally I think it was thanksgiving.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was right at Thanksgiving.
And I intercepted up a letter that she had gotten from Bart.
And how do you intercept the letter?
No,
I it was all above board,
but
we'll leave it at that,
I guess.
I guess we're going to leave that one.
I gay.
I confronted her,
this Skype Bart.
Oh No,
it's,
no,
we're serious and we're going to get married someday.
In fact,
he's coming to Kansas for Christmas.
I said,
I'm making a deal with you.
I don't think he's coming for Christmas.
And so if he comes,
I'll back off and you don't have to worry about me trying to kiss you anymore.
But if he doesn't come,
then you and I go steady.
Well,
he didn't come.
And so I,
that,
that started at a wonderful relationship.
We,
uh,
then went steady in high school of course.
And then I go off to the Naval Academy for peace from Kansas and um,
and she went to University of Kansas for her first year there.
And,
but we continued to communicate and,
and I say,
well,
I saw her at Christmas time when I came home and then she decided to move to
Washington DC to work for a senator out there.
And so she spent the next three years,
the last three years naval academy,
they're close enough so that we continue to see each other.
So it was,
um,
and it was one of those,
uh,
you know,
one and only kind of a thing cause I didn't really date a whole lot in high
school and she was yet for sure.
So then you guys got married,
did you,
did you wait until you graduated from the Naval Academy?
You,
no,
you can't,
you can't get married while you were at the Naval Academy.
At least you're not supposed to.
A couple of guys did and I didn't.
And so the day after I graduated from the Naval Academy,
uh,
we were,
we were married and my six buddy is held up their swords while one was a marine.
And so he held up his saber as we came down from the chapel through the arch of
swords.
And it was a beautiful day and a beautiful wedding.
And from there we went immediately to flight training.
Did you,
when did you find out you were getting picked up?
The flight trainer.
Our senior?
Yeah.
The last,
uh,
last part of our senior year you could apply and uh,
and then you go through all of the hoops that a,
that you go through to try to qualify for naval aviation.
So I found out probably a month or six weeks before I graduated.
That was going to be my,
my,
my tour.
Do you graduate in [inaudible] 64?
Yes.
So when you graduated,
did you guys,
were you guys thinking Vietnam already know?
Was it just too early and there was limited operation so it wasn't really
something that you,
a graduate thinking about front of mind?
I don't remember ever hearing the word Vietnam while I was in the Naval Academy.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you rolled to flight school just thinking,
Hey,
we're going to fly around,
we're going to go do regular deployments.
Were you'd to heard about,
but you weren't thinking about Vietnam?
Yup.
So at what point was that in flight school when you first started thinking of
yourself?
Yes.
Here we got guys over here dropping bombs.
Yeah,
we'll have Averett ev Alvarez was shot down the first a pod to be shot down and
August,
1964.
Okay.
So it became a reality that while I was in flight training and another naval
aviator was in prison in Vietnam.
Now I didn't,
you know,
I didn't understand the politics.
I didn't question the politics of it at all.
I just did the best I could and flight training and the and enjoyed it,
you know.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a kick.
Did you guys,
did your,
did your attitudes shifted also for,
for my generation,
when all of a sudden September 11th happened,
it was like,
it was like a paradigm shift and everyone's mentality that that day it such a
clear,
clear demonstration and we all knew that we are going to war.
And that was an immediate attitude shift.
Did you guys start to have a shift in attitude or was it because the way Vietnam
escalated more slowly?
Was it more of a,
a slow escalation in your minds as well?
No,
it was a very slow,
um,
you know,
the little story of,
uh,
of the,
of the frog in the pot of boiling water,
you know,
jumps out in a hurry.
But,
but no,
it was a,
it just warmed up very slowly for us.
And,
uh,
I didn't even as I went through fight training,
you know,
I mean I learned to drop bombs and shoot guns and all that stuff.
And it was,
it was a challenging and,
uh,
it was exciting,
but I,
I didn't see the reality of it.
I didn't really picture myself as being in combat.
Um,
and so of course when I got my wings and then was assigned the f four Phantom,
which at the time was the hottest airplane in the world,
mean we had the time to climb and records and the speed records.
And it's a,
it's a twice the speed of sound airplane.
And it was,
felt very fortunate to,
uh,
to have been assigned that airplane.
And so I came out here to San Diego to a,
to fly.
And you were talking about in your book,
you'd done a mid shipment tour where,
uh,
a phantom went down,
both pilots killed and,
and then you got to sign the f the fandom.
I did that give you any reservations at all?
Uh,
I don't remember being afraid of the airplane,
uh,
but I certainly gave it a lot of respect and especially around the ship,
because it's,
um,
you know,
I saw this thing go down at the Naval Academy and the summertime you get exposed
to the possible built you might have in the future.
So we go play marine for a while and we'd go to submarines for a while and,
and we go aboard ships,
uh,
it to,
to be line officers for awhile and we go to,
uh,
to,
to Pensacola.
And so I got a little touch of it there of actually being in airplanes.
And then my senior,
my senior cruise,
between my junior and senior year,
I'm going to board the,
the Constellation,
the aircraft carrier,
constellation and a,
and we were out of Sasebo Japan and I'm watching flight ops from the bridge.
And so,
you know,
I'm looking down at this,
uh,
the airplanes,
launching and recovering on this aircraft carrier and I've had him came in and
actually broke the wire.
The pilot did okay,
but he broke keep,
he picked up the wire and the wire snapped this cable that traps and airplane is
two and a half inches in diameter.
It's a very thick steel wire round cable.
I'm is a really,
really strong because it has to stop this 35,000 pound airplane going down to
shoot at 170 miles an hour.
So,
but uh,
for whatever reason the cable broke.
Okay.
The cable snapped around in,
it cut off the of three different guys who are on the deck.
Okay.
And it was so fast that I couldn't even,
I couldn't even see it.
My eyes couldn't even follow this cable because there was just,
I mean,
there's so much pressure,
so much energy involved.
And then the airplane,
the f four was slowed down to the point where the guy couldn't get it back in
the air.
And so it just dribbled off the bow of the aircraft carrier in the end of the
water.
Well,
of course then I then I turned my view to the stern of the ship to see if I
could see what had happened with the few seconds that it took from when it's
settled in the water until I could see out the back of the,
of the ship.
It was gone.
There was no debris,
there was no oil,
there was nothing in the water behind this shit at this airplane and gone down.
So it was a shock to me,
of course.
Um,
but,
you know,
I think I started out with this mentality that is always going to happen to
somebody else,
you know,
never me.
And,
um,
and that I'm,
you know,
whatever happened,
I'm going to do it better.
And,
um,
and I think that's,
well,
you know,
this better than I,
you have to kind of have that mentality in combat.
You can't go in thinking you're going to get killed.
And so,
um,
so I,
I wasn't reluctant to fly the f four,
but I gave it I,
I think,
uh,
respect.
So you get that and you come out,
you're stationed in San Diego or San Diego,
right,
for when you,
when you're deployed for the first time Miramar Naval air station.
And that's where I helped start top gun.
That was kind of an interesting experience as well.
There was a,
there was a,
a,
a pool of students to fly the f four Phantom.
And I showed up here when they had about a six month waiting list for me to find
this airplane.
Well,
six months was a long time,
you know,
for a 23 year old kid.
And,
uh,
I wanted to get in the air.
So a buddy of mine,
Paul creaky and I had gotten our wings at the same time.
It had been assigned the f four Phantom and we came out here and so we were both
going to have to wait for six months to find this airplane.
So we wandered down the flight line at Miramar and found the instrument training
squadron was flying the same airplane that we had flown in in flight chain of
the EOF nine a cougar wing airplane.
It's a,
it's a jet but it's lightened slow and kind of stodgy is a,
it's a Korean warping.
And,
and they were,
they were using it in flight training to teach instruments.
And the way they do this,
the instructor would sit in the front seat and the students sit in the back seat
and they had a bag that,
that covered all the windows covered,
covered you up.
All you could see was the instrument panel.
You're under this bag.
And so,
um,
and so we signed on to fly this airplane for test hops and check rides and this
kind of stuff just to fly that just stay in the air because we were already
qualified.
The airplane,
well Kooky and I would save a little bit of gas.
Okay.
Each time we'd fly these students around.
At the end of the hop,
we would lurk off the,
the coast of San Diego and wait for the phantom is to come out.
And,
uh,
so we,
you know,
we,
these guys would come off and run away at Miramar and they were heavy,
you know,
and they were stodgy and they were slow as they came off.
And they'd get about four or five miles out in the Pacific and we would pounce
on these guys.
And,
uh,
it was all kinds of fun because we were lighter and could turn quicker than the
fandoms.
You know,
we were a smaller,
we had a better wing load than they did.
And so we could turn inside these guys.
Of course,
they were much,
much faster.
We were not supersonic,
and they were so they could get away from us in,
in a heartbeat if they wanted to.
But,
uh,
we,
we started this air combat maneuvering with these guys.
Well,
that went on for,
I don't know,
a couple of months until one day,
cookie and I,
I mean,
we played the role.
We had white scarves,
you know,
snoopy goggles and the whole works.
And when he came back and to the instruments squadron and checked in our
airplanes back in and the,
and it was signed on the Bolton Board,
plum creaky report to the f four commanding officer immediately,
uh,
we were in trouble.
So two to two guys and they're sweaty flight suits,
knock on the door of the commanding officer of the Phantom Squadron.
I'll never forget this scene.
The,
the,
uh,
the got come in and we opened the door.
This guy sits at a long desk.
Okay.
And Andy,
he's got glasses and of course he's an old,
old guy.
We were 23,
so,
you know,
he was probably 30,
but he,
the littlest guy you've ever talked to.
And so he's sitting there and talked to him at the top of his glasses.
He's in a sweaty flight suit also,
which should have been our first indication.
He said,
you two guys out there and the f nines Haslin my fighter pilots.
Um,
yes sir.
We were.
Um,
did you follow a phantom through an entire loop?
Uh,
yesterday.
In fact,
we did.
He said,
did you have your gun sights on that Phantom the entire time?
Um,
yeah.
Yes sir,
we did.
He said,
do you know who was in that Phantom?
I was,
he said,
I just came back from Vietnam are kill ratio over there is terrible.
They're eating our lunch.
We need to learn how to fight this airplane.
See,
the f four was designed during the cold war as a supersonic intercept.
I was never a fighter pilot.
And in fact,
I trained in a space suit so I could go above 50,000 feet,
you know,
off the aircraft carrier,
climbed 80,000 feet,
shoot down the Russian bombers and you know,
at 45 degree angle of bank turn return to the aircraft carrier.
That was my job.
I wasn't supposed to be out there hassling cause because it was the Cold War,
we did not expect to have,
uh,
a Korean War,
World War II type a hassle.
The fighter pilot.
Well,
of course Vietnam came around and suddenly,
you know,
they're,
they're flying these older airplanes that were eating our lunch.
So the CEO looked at us and he said,
you want to you in a fight with me tomorrow?
I'm all,
yes sir.
That'd be fun.
So for the next two or three months,
ball creaky and I,
with our white scarves and our snoopy goggles,
we get Nardo left.
We had to start about an hour ahead of time,
you know,
just because they were so fast.
But we'd get out to see if he'd go out to 40 miles out to sea and then turn
around and here they come.
And we'd had these two on two engagements and,
and that became a syllabus within the replacement air group.
But the air force that eventually became the top gun school.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
it was.
It was the start of a,
of retraining.
Well,
and it was,
it was very successful.
We turned our kill ratio around by teaching pilots how to fight this f four
phantom.
Yeah.
Clearly that's it.
Without training to fight,
how are you going to know how to fight?
That's right.
And you gotta you gotta beat,
that's outstanding for the,
for the commanding officer,
that squadron to say,
you know what?
Instead of being,
instead of being mad that you were doing it.
Instead he's humble and says,
you know what?
We need to get better at this.
Yeah,
let's,
let's keep training.
Yup.
That's awesome.
And you eventually do get your time in the f four Phantom.
You've learned how to fly that and now it's time to go on deployment.
You're going on deployment now and November 5th,
1966 you kiss and goodbye and you go on deployment on the,
on the Kitty Hawk.
It was her birthday.
Oh,
that's a great birthday present officer.
Very nice of you.
It's like my first daughter,
my first daughter was born actual birthday.
Like actual birthday.
Yeah.
I went on deployment the next day.
Everyone was really happy with me on that one.
When now when you were
going through the flight training and you were getting ready to deploy now,
were you thinking about Vietnam at all?
I mean,
you must've been getting feedback when you got feedback from the commanding
officer,
so now your focus had shifted something.
Yeah,
it certainly had.
And the squadron that I joined was just coming back from Vietnam and they'd had
quite a few casual
taste and uh,
and so they were talking about,
you know,
the guys were,
were giving us instruction on how to work that.
Another thing about the phantom was that we had,
uh,
we had no indication when a missile was in the air,
because we were faster than the missile for the most part are higher than the
missile.
And so one of the things the guys,
the guys told me that the fellows coming back from Vietnam said,
go down to radio shack and buy herself a Fuzzbuster,
you know?
Oh,
like,
oh,
look,
police detective.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The old fuzzbuster.
Yeah,
it's a,
he said,
because the Russian built Sam surface to air missiles are on the same frequency
as a California highway patrol.
True.
True Story.
Uh,
and so we have found that if you,
because we have no indication in the airplane when a missile is in the air.
And so I did a mental radio shack by myself if fuzzbuster and uh,
it had little suction cup and you look the Suction Cup and you put it on the
windscreen and this,
this fandom and you run a little white wire,
you know,
down underneath your a g suit and you're sore,
torsional harness and under your oxygen mask and,
and finally into your ear,
you know,
you get your butt in there.
And so here I am flying this $20 million airplane being protected by a $29 first
buster.
So it worked.
But uh,
the problem was that there was no direction capability.
You can tell where it was coming from.
And so,
you know,
it's almost a worst sideways psychologically.
Absolutely.
You heard the warble and boy,
you know,
you started to turn and Jink and you know,
your,
your head went on a swivel trying to figure out where this,
this missile is you,
but you get overseas and you're,
you're flying,
you start flying missions,
you're doing,
you're doing mostly strike missions.
Is that primarily what you're doing,
taking out targets in North Vietnam?
The four of course,
again was considered,
was configured and built from the Keel up as a a,
as an air to air combat machine.
All right.
The powers that be decided,
hey,
there's an airplane,
we can hang a bomb on it.
They put on an extra,
I believe four hardpoints in the bottom of this airplane,
maybe five,
I can't remember.
So that we could carry bombs on this fighter airplane.
What we were supposed to be interceptors.
We weren't supposed to be carrying bombs around,
but we found out that sure enough,
this big ole airplane was a pretty good platform for,
for dropping bombs.
And so we could carry,
you know,
we could carry 12,
13,000 pounds of bombs into the target,
which was a pretty good load.
You know,
we can also support,
you know,
guys like you and the ground that,
uh,
with all kinds of various kinds of weaponry.
Um,
and so what happened was we had a sister squadron on the aircraft carrier.
So for a month line period,
we would be fighters for two weeks and then we would,
we would,
we would reconfigure airplane to be bombers and we'd be bombers for two weeks
and we would go back to fighters and then back monomers.
The,
and so to answer your question,
half the time over there,
I was dropping bombs and half the time I was uh,
I was uh,
doing the air to air
mission and the air to air mission primarily be doing combat air patrols to
support the other elements that were flying in with bombs.
And you'd be protected in case any mig showed up.
Exactly,
yeah.
It was the CAAP a cap combat air patrol.
So you're pretty much
almost done with deployment where we're talking,
you,
you spend,
you did what,
74 missions at this point.
You've been there for five or coming up on six months and on the 19th of May,
1967,
you get a phone call and you guys get like a,
a strike mission comes in that you are supposed to execute.
It was a big deal.
Uh,
and it was called an Alpha strike.
And Alpha strike was the top priority.
And we knew that it would be a lot of airplanes in the air and we have some
pretty important targets to hit.
And it was sanctioned straight from the Pentagon.
It was jcs stuff.
Uh,
and um,
which of course is one of the problems in that war was in most of our
instruction came from the guys,
uh,
back in the puzzle palace.
And,
uh,
I,
it's,
you know,
they wouldn't,
they wouldn't let us decide targets or attitudes or anything else.
It was pretty well,
well planned by the time we got the go.
And I got a call,
I suppose three in the morning,
something like that,
saying that I was to schedule this flight.
I was a scheduled so officer for the pro for the squadron.
And so I was the guy that figured out who went on what strikes and with whom and
in the airplanes that they head.
And so,
so I got up early to start planning this strike,
uh,
with the airplanes and the pilots and the back seeders our radar intercept
officers are copilots.
Um,
and,
and so I did.
Then we went to the briefing room and got about an hour brief on this,
these targets.
I later found out that the reason for the whole thing,
the reason why we were doing an Alpha strike on the 19th of May was it was the
birthday of their president Holcim in and again,
exactly the brilliance of,
uh,
you know,
of our PSI or Psi war,
um,
grades was that we would catch them in celebration of their,
of the big day,
uh,
because they,
it was like our president's Day,
they had picnics and that kind of stuff.
And so we were going to catch them with their pants down.
Well,
as most things that happened in Vietnam,
they knew we were coming for whatever reason.
And,
uh,
that day they were eight f four phantom shot down.
But I'll never forget the beginning of it because,
um,
you know,
I took off and then a rendezvous with a tanker and took on an extra 3000 pounds
of fuel and then joined this,
the squadron.
And it was in fact the cat mission.
It was a combat air patrol.
I was not carrying bombs.
So we had four of us on one side of the strike group and for the other and just
to look because it was three aircraft carriers and five air force bases,
all just throwing everything we had at the end of me that day.
It was uh,
it was an amazing armada and I could see from one horizon to the other,
these airplanes and uh,
and I remember feeling really proud,
you know,
man,
just to be a part of this doing something that very few people in the world
would ever do.
Um,
and flying this airplane,
um,
at age 24.
And uh,
so that,
that was how it all began on the 19th of May.
At one of the things that we were talking about just before we hit record was
the kind of the sense of humor that you have in the military and,
and what that's like.
And one of the,
by the way,
I haven't even mentioned that referring to a book that you wrote called,
I'm no hero by Charlie plumb and that'll be,
that's available on Amazon.
Get it through.
It'd be link on the website but also book actually better on my website because
I sign everyone that a that goes out.
So my website,
Charlie plumb.com.
Okay,
well there you go.
Even better
did the book here you guys are getting before you launch you're getting ready to
launch kind of getting ready for the briefing and here we go.
The pilots of the fighter planes gathered in their own briefing room and read
from a television screen and teletype the weather information and the position
of the ship we reviewed once again the switches we would have to throw and I
coordinated with the maintenance officer,
the weapons we would need,
the volume of the fuel,
etc. Serious thoughts were in the back of all our minds,
but outwardly our mood was light.
We laughed and joked,
drank coffee and smoked my regular Rio,
which is the radar intercept officer does their backseater cause the the f four
Phantom has two people was up to his old habit of manipulating his slide rule
being a self styled math wizard.
He again pinpointed his likelihood of getting bagged or shot down.
This was based on some speculative formula he had found somewhere today.
Friends,
he proclaimed my bag factor is 0.019376 and then you reply to them then save me
a room at the Hanoi Hilton.
Again.
I'm glad you're still laughing about that sir.
Uh,
the rest of you,
as we go through this book,
we'll see the true irony in that joke.
Uh,
you know,
back to the book here,
we left our ready room and entered the central briefing room where all the Reos
and standby crew scrutinize their master plan,
which included maps and photographs of the targets and intelligence for sports
of enemies fire capability.
After our central briefing,
we returned to our ready room,
meditated last minute instructions and put it on our flight gear altogether.
These briefings took as long and sometimes longer than the mission itself.
I looked up at the screen pilots,
man,
your aircraft,
we gave each other,
we slapped each other on the back,
the exchange of customary,
give him hell dialogue and patted the posterior of our good luck girl hanging on
the door.
It was time to go top side.
You guys are now getting ready to take off and again,
just some of this,
this humor back to the book engine run up as good takeoff checklist is complete.
I'm ready to go,
Gary.
You Ready?
Yeah,
I'm ready.
Okay.
I mocked,
this is your captain speaking.
Welcome to flight four oh three to annoy north Vietnam will be flying an
altitude of 11 grand and we have a high ceiling.
Make sure your seat belt is fastened.
No Smoking please.
So that's the attitude going out and legitimately yours.
This is your 75th mission.
You've just flown 74 you're feeling pretty comfortable.
I mean even though of course you've got thoughts in the back of your mind,
but you're feeling pretty comfortable about how you do your job and what you get
done.
I am feeling bulletproof.
I wasn't going to go that far,
but let's just go there because I know that feeling to
the,
as you push in back to the book,
all this coordination,
so it's what you just talked about,
this massive effort going forward,
dozens and dozens of aircraft,
all of this coordination of and machinery during the refueling was done in
complete silence.
We called it zip lip.
Although enemy radar would have already detected us.
We were careful not to give radio spooks any additional information.
It was gratifying to experience such close rapport with my airwing.
I knew and they knew what each was doing in this intricate maneuver yet not a
word had to be spoken and that's,
I've,
I've actually talked about that on here when we would train and when I was
running training for,
for the seals,
I would tell them,
hey,
you're not allowed to talk during this training mission or you can't say one
word to each other and it was amazing.
After you do that a couple times,
how much better people get cause they're reading,
they're reacting,
they're anticipating one other people are going to do.
And you guys are just so far ahead at this point,
five and a half months into deployment,
it's,
you guys are doing this whole thing without saying a word to each other.
It was amazing.
Yeah.
I think that's one of the,
one of the incredible things about the military as you,
even though you're just a little piece of that big machine,
this big powerful machine,
it's,
it's pretty awesome to experience when you,
when that stuff's going on
and you kind of talked about what,
what you were doing,
you are positioned on the flanks anticipating,
how often do you
guys see it
migs there not,
uh,
not often.
I had seen migs probably four or five times up to that point.
And um,
so they,
they,
they really were,
they were,
they were really good about not showing up until they knew that they could kill
something.
No.
Uh,
of course they were,
they had the advantage,
they had the home field advantage and so they could wait on their basis until we
came to them and then they would launch.
So if you didn't get close to a Mig base,
you probably weren't going to see what they were.
They had a very short range,
uh,
and,
and uh,
they didn't see in the air very long.
And so,
uh,
we didn't see him very often.
And on this one,
you get a call though,
you here,
they don't,
they give you a call for,
there's migs,
what does it migs it 20,
20 west and you start to get a little aggressive start leading out that way a
little bit,
right?
Yup,
Yup.
The flight commander tighten you up and said,
hey,
plumb,
get back over information.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
uh,
my,
my best buddy there at any wisely,
he had already shot down two airplanes,
uh,
by that time and he shot it down another one after I was shot down.
Uh,
and so he,
it,
and,
you know,
I mean,
that's what every fighter pilot wants to,
you know,
to have a Mig to his credit.
And I saw this opportunity,
you know,
five days to go,
this is,
this is my,
this is my day,
you know,
this is Charlie Plumb Day.
So I started ease out of the squadron so that I would be the first to go after
this Mig.
And,
uh,
it's,
you're only plums are going to get his,
that's what happens.
But no,
that,
that's,
that's how it began.
And the,
and they tied you back up,
so you fall back into formation and now there's a sense,
is there a Sam call?
Did you pick it up on the,
on the fuzzbuster?
I did,
but there were a lot of them in the air and,
and uh,
and,
and so that thing was warbling all the time.
Um,
they were,
they were salvo in there.
Sam's that day,
they just,
they just shoot a bunch of them off at the same time.
And so every time they shot one off,
then every time their radar would scan me,
I would get to fuzzbuster.
But we also had,
you know,
we had the uh,
um,
the big radar airplanes in the sky at the same time and,
and,
and they would call us and that's how I got that call,
that 20 mile away call was,
uh,
was,
was from our electronic folks that were flying well above us with the radar.
So you know that there's Sam surface to air missiles up there and here we go
back to the book,
Gary,
that's your,
that's your real sitting behind you in the plane.
You say,
Gary,
do you see it?
And he says,
I don't see a thing,
Charlie.
We both seen Sam's before.
They resembled flying white telephone poles with huge 4th of July
sparklers.
Spring Silvery orange glows from their tails.
If we saw them in time,
we could dodge the missiles by letting them close in at the last second,
polling the plane into a high g barrel roll,
six g's or so,
and letting the polls pass harmlessly underneath because if it's designed to
missile,
could not follow us without cracking into,
but we didn't see it.
Boom.
I felt a thump and the orphanage,
the half section of the airplane,
airplane read instrument lights jumped across the panel indicating that I had
two engines on fire that wasn't good.
This plane only had two engines.
I yanked the throttles back to idle and the birds seem to come to an immediate
halt in midair.
Charlie were hit.
How bad is it?
She's still flying.
Then the aircraft started a role and while I mad we scanned the instruments.
I looked up and found that the f four it's suddenly overturned.
Ground was where there was where there should have been sky and the nose was
heading downward,
ripping air at 500 knots.
The altimeter needle collapse to 4,000 then 3,500 than 3000 we had to get out,
but being inverted,
we would be rocketed by the ejection seat right into the rice patties.
I had rolled the plane upright.
I tried to stick.
It was frozen.
The only manual control was the rudder pedal.
Not normally used to roll an aircraft.
I stepped on it as hard as I could.
Adrenaline surging through my veins.
The plane shuttered once and again.
Slowly it began to write itself.
Rear view mirrors reflected a screaming fireball.
12,000 pounds of framing gasoline in 30,000 pounds of fissionable aircraft.
You want to eject?
No.
Wait a minute.
I shouted back.
The plane struggled than the sky was where it should be.
Gary,
let's go.
I jerked my face curtain to eject.
The rockets slam me out of the aircraft.
I tumbled a couple of times and the shoot caught just as advertised.
All kinds of debris filled the air around me as wadding from the shells whistled
by son of a gun.
They've backed my airplane now thereafter,
me,
I went to the concussions from the exploding shells.
Sonic booms,
battering my year drums,
rockets of heavy smoke,
clouds of the sky,
dairy and I had adjusted,
ejected so near the ground,
however,
that enemy guns could train on us.
For only a short time.
I checked my parachute canopy.
It looked good.
Torn in only a couple of places I thought of escape,
but were looking away.
I saw my buddies and their aircraft to blending into the horizon.
Below my landing zone was nothing but bear in rice patties down to my left,
a huge cloud of black smoke billowed at the outskirts of
a peasant.
Hamlet punctuating a row of four or five cuts.
My plane had it wiped out a family.
If so,
the villagers would certainly be unhappy.
I wasn't happy either.
I hadn't intended that to happen.
I later learned that the plan the plane had impacted just beyond the last shack
on the road.
There was precious little time before I could touch down,
before I would touch down and I had much to be done.
I grabbed my two way radio and tried to contact Gary,
but I received no answer.
Then I called my skipper Lynnfield lead Lynnfield lead.
This is Lynnfield too.
We've got two good shoots.
We're going to be all right.
Request no SAR effort.
And Sar is search and rescue.
For those of you that don't know.
And I,
when I read that part right there,
I stopped in my tracks because here you are,
you're shot down,
you're in a parachute,
you're going to obviously be landing in these rice patties surrounded by enemy.
And you had the wherewithal to understand that if you requested for search and
rescue to come and get you,
it was just going to get more people killed.
Yeah.
Uh,
and that had happened before.
I,
I'd seen,
I had seen that happen and uh,
we were so far behind.
Enemy lines mean it was impossible.
A jolly green was that,
what was it called,
science for the helicopter that would come get us off the aircraft carrier and
they would have to go through,
uh,
probably a 75 or 100 miles of enemy territory before they ever got to me.
And,
uh,
and,
and I was in such a populated area that I could see that they were,
that I was going to be captured immediately.
And so to get those guys,
to put them in harm's way was,
um,
it was kind of selling.
So that's why I did that.
When,
you know,
I've experienced a couple times in combat where things slow down and the time
starts to,
to really be different than it normally is.
And they say it's because you get this big adrenaline dump and all of your
sensors,
all your,
your perception awakens to such a high point that things actually slow down.
Did you experience any of that when you were,
once that Sam missile hit?
I did,
yes.
Uh,
it was almost like slow motion and I,
you know,
and I remember thinking this is unreal.
I,
I've,
I've never had this happen to me before,
but it was almost like I was in a,
it was an iMovie and everything was slowing down in my life.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I,
you know,
I tried to,
since every possible thing,
because of course I'm thinking escape now,
trying to get it,
get out of here in some way.
And so I'm trying to memorize all the little roads I could see in all the little
trees and all little Hudson.
Where are they in,
where am I that situation?
Situational awareness.
How far from the water in the ocean,
where you at the school?
I was 75 miles,
no chance of that.
And no chance.
We were on the outskirts of Hanoi,
the capital city and,
uh,
and,
and that was the bad news.
Good News.
The bad news was that I was going to be captured immediately.
There was no chance whatsoever.
I mean,
they were shooting at me from the ground while I came down.
Uh,
the good news was I didn't have to go very far to the,
to a formalized prison camp like a lot of the guys did,
you know,
you had bill reader on this,
on your podcast and he was dragged for,
I dunno,
weeks.
Um,
and,
uh,
because he was the,
he was captured in South Vietnam,
right?
The guys that were in Laos or Cambodia who were brought to our prison camps were
all just really torn up,
not just because of,
um,
of the enemy,
but just because of the rigors of the travel.
So,
and you're going to,
you're going to talk about this,
you talk about in the book,
but you know,
just to kind of point out the fact that whatever,
two minutes earlier,
you were part of this giant powerful force with a multimillion dollar aircraft
under your command is a 24 year old as part of this group that have many,
many multimillion dollar with this huge destructive power launching off of these
ships and airfields.
And to go from having all that to now you're under a parachute and you're about
to have all of that just absolutely taken away.
It was a major transition in my life,
but I,
you know,
uh,
unlike,
unlike someone who's diagnosed with cancer,
right?
You know,
or like someone who,
who just lost a job or uh,
just lots of child or just had a car accident.
I mean that's,
you know,
there are similarities in normal civilian life.
I think that can be just as impactive as being blown out of the sky.
Yeah,
you're floating down to earth and I'm going back to the book.
Then I bowed my head,
well,
Lord,
here I am.
I'm really in a bind now and I need some help.
Give me strength and give an strength.
I was surprised at how calm I was when I should've been panic stricken,
but there was too much to think about and do.
I couldn't let myself become irrational.
It would all be different now.
I tried to envision myself in this new world and prepare for it.
I had a lot going for me.
I was in good physical condition and I could probably withstand torture.
I didn't believe I would be killed because I was too much of a blue chip for the
enemy.
Which again for you to say you're,
you're shot down,
you're to land in enemy territory and your statement is,
I had a lot going.
For me.
It's a positive attitude.
Circuits.
That's your philosophy of saying good as my notes right there.
I wrote good knock this before,
so you've touched down.
I plunged backward into the mud and water trying to get my bearings.
I took off my helmet and mask and crawled out,
crawled without direction in the quagmire with slimy hands.
I tried to wipe mud from my eyes.
I saw that I was about 10 or 15 yards from an embankment.
I looked over to see that Gary touching down or an adjacent patty about 100
yards away had disappeared behind the eight foot embankment,
a barefoot peasant wearing khaki shirts,
shorts and t shirt ran at top speed down the path toward me,
grimacing with excitement and anger above his head.
He waved a double edged acts with blades about eight inches long.
My instructors never documented that type of weapon.
I heard him scream hand up,
hanging up.
I didn't understand what he meant and I kept working with my gear and shoot.
I had a 38 revolver strapped to my chest and it,
and as long as he stayed in the embankment,
I would not touch it.
It wasn't long.
However,
before 10 or 12 more peasants came rushing toward me yelling and waving their
shovels and hoes.
Now there was power in numbers and they charged out in the water after me.
I raised my hands away from my body.
They started ripping my g suit,
found my survival knife,
and proceeded to cut away at the suit and the torso harness.
I tried to tell them to use the zippers and even attempted to show them how to
do it,
but they knocked my hands away.
The more certain they were that I was harmless,
the meaner they became.
The shovel and hold blades flailed up my body to prove to me that I was there.
Loath captain
captive.
Strangely,
the peasants failed to see my revolver,
probably because it too was covered with mud and the 38 restaurant in my holster
at least three or four minutes before a peasant finally spotted it.
He yanked it out of the holster and slashed a few steps away.
A moment later,
he returned and screamed for special attention.
You fixed the barrel to my head,
I could see that at least two of the chambers were empty.
I had always kept five of the six chambers loaded,
so I knew that he must've removed at least one of the cartridges.
There was little I could do as I felt the muddy barrel against my temple.
The peasant pulled the trigger
click.
He could fought and sneaked away wiping off his unexpected prize.
You're
as far as
your thoughts about being killed at that moment,
did you accept them that you will use this thinking he's not going to do it?
What's your attitude at that point?
I'd never in the entire experience and never thought I was going to be killed
and I didn't think so.
Thanks.
So at that moment,
of course I was very happy with it.
I heard the click of that revolver,
but uh,
but it was anger.
It was actually very encouraging to think that they were going to feign this,
uh,
execution and not go through with it.
And,
uh,
it was encouraging to me to think that yeah,
they were going to hammer me around and get me pretty bloody,
but they probably weren't intentionally going to kill me.
I guess I worried more about that.
They would kill me accidentally,
uh,
then intentionally,
but,
and there were two or three times during the entire experience was one of them
is while I was being tortured a how,
when I felt like I was losing it and I was close to death and they,
they loosened the ropes,
uh,
because they saw,
I think that I was getting pretty close to death.
And so,
uh,
and that,
you know,
again,
that was good because I bet.
All right,
uh,
this is hurts a lot,
but it looks like they're not going to kill me.
I may wish I was dead,
but I don't think they're going to do it.
Now you guys are blindfolded.
They take capture Gary as well and there you're,
you're blindfolded.
But at this point they put this kind of marginal blindfold on you that's not
working really well.
So you can actually see,
and again,
I'm going to go to your,
um,
go ahead and highlight your twisted sense of humor here.
So here we go.
Uh,
you're in the back of an old Russian jeep.
Back to the book.
Gary was held captive in the jeep ahead of mine at the incident.
I recognize Gary.
I started calling hysterically for a doctor to tend to his burned arms.
The guards restrained me violently screaming foreign but distinct warnings to
attempt no more communication.
I did however,
shout one more thing.
I don't know why,
unless it was for morale.
I shouted out these people or a thousand years behind in blindfolds
and it says later the POW is who were nearby cells.
Heard,
heard you screaming that and still laughed about it.
So,
uh,
I'm glad you kept your sense of humor.
You know,
sometimes I look back on that and think that I,
that I was in some form of shock because I mean,
who would,
who would come up with that would,
who would write this stuff?
And uh,
they,
they bring,
they bring you in it from kind of parade you guys around and you hear camera's
clicking and eventually you get put into new guy village and you get put into,
you know,
a torture basically of torture room.
So here we go.
Back to the book,
several torture cells and the prison,
the Green Nabi Room,
so called because the walls and ceiling were covered with gobs of plaster,
the size of golf balls,
which looked somewhat like mud,
dobber nests.
The globs had a particular function,
acoustics to muffle human sound.
Now you get through this day sunset,
I had difficulty in seeing what was beyond myself.
So I began reminiscing about the world of active life.
I have loved so much outside my,
every minute had been filled outside.
I had been king the skies outside.
I had been continually learning,
doing,
accomplishing.
I had been proud,
so very proud.
And now I was tired,
so tired,
so perplexed,
so confined,
so very lonely.
The trauma of overwhelming changed caused my mind to reel with this orientation.
Okay?
I was afraid.
I stared at the emptiness.
Shadows crept up the walls gradually becoming more pronounced.
Curiously,
a vague ghostlike impression materialized.
The image took the appearance of the master with arms outstretched,
a symbol.
It was strange,
yet something I felt I should expect.
I began to utter the first lines of the 23rd psalm.
The Lord is my shepherd.
I shall not want.
He maketh me to lie down in green pastures.
He leadeth me beside the still waters.
He restoreth my soul.
He leadeth me in the paths of righteousness for his name's sake.
I repeated it allowed several times,
not because of any deep religious drive,
but because it's simply seemed the thing to do.
And then I prayed.
I considered making a deal with God,
but rejected the idea.
I made no big promises and asked for no miracles.
Just strength.
Okay.
Strength to endure the hardship and strength from my wife,
Anne.
It'd be difficult for her to,
okay.
Yea though I walk through the Valley of the shadow of death.
That was certainly where I was
an interesting point here is that in Colonel Readers podcast,
uh,
you found the same thing that he went to the 23rd psalm then,
um,
uh,
and again it was just almost like,
well this is what I should do.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Well I say there's no atheists in foxholes and I guess there aren't any in the
prison camp,
although you do talk about some atheists in the prison camp.
I do as a matter of fact come with a couple of guys to consider themselves
atheist and,
and you know,
the,
you also talk about faith and one of the things that I am glad we'll get to
this,
but when you talk about faith,
your,
you talk about faith not just in God,
but faith in your country and all the one that I think that regardless of what
someone's religious beliefs,
our faith in yourself.
Absolutely.
And I think all three of those or whichever one of those faiths where you find
strength in times like this,
lean on it.
Absolutely.
And,
and,
you know,
faith in the team as well.
We had to have faith in each other and that was awfully important to,
you know,
to be a part of a group like that that could trust one another.
How quickly did you realize that there was,
that you were part of that?
I guess we'll get to it,
but I mean,
when you first got your in this room,
did you feel completely isolated at first?
And there's no one else here?
No.
I knew that two or other prisoners there,
I could hear them.
Uh,
you know,
some of them were being tortured as I was.
I could hear the torture.
I could.
Um,
you know,
I,
I could peek out sometimes and see them walking by my cell.
So I knew there were other prisoners in the area and they just wouldn't let me,
they would let me talk to them.
So the interrogation begins,
the torture begins.
We're going back to the book,
we read copy regulations.
You obey,
you live no trouble.
Okay.
I did not respond.
First Regulation,
you answer all questions.
The way that the north Vietnamese justified torture was peculiar.
When they asked me questions and wanted military answers,
I was not tortured to answer questions but punished for disobeying camp
regulations.
What?
What airplane?
You fly.
I'm sorry.
I can't tell you.
Okay.
Lamb and they were calling you lamb.
What airplane to answer this question was of course not in my rules.
I'm sorry.
I can't answer that.
The officer again reminded me about the punishment for disobeying camp rules.
Yeah.
Okay.
You talk me or you talk steel
to which you responded.
Bring it on.
Okay.
The two higher ranking officials left the remaining officer with one word
ordered the guards forward.
They brought it on the steel mentioned by the interrogator consistent of iron
manacles,
shackles and a leg bar.
The shackles were cylindrical iron bars shaped like horse shoes but rounded at
the end so that the five foot leg bar could be slipped into them and locked the
prisoner.
His ankles could then be forced through the openings and secured by the bar.
The junior officer walked out,
guards blindfolded me,
forced my wrists behind my back and place the open jaws.
The medicals around them.
These had obviously been intended for the more modest Vietnamese arms.
They were so small that they had to be forced together just so the screw could
be seated in the bottom of the threads with what looked like a roller skate key
or guard began to turn the screw.
My skin was pinched between the metal and quickly succumb to the vice.
Okay.
I screamed in agony.
Surely the guards wouldn't get these things much tighter.
Blood ooze down my hands and steal.
The guard kept turning the key like powerful magnets.
The iron was finally set,
flush circulation stopped my hands burned grayish blue tingled and became numb
regard.
Then wrap the rope first round my left elbow and then around my right and drew
my elbows together behind my back,
my shoulder muscles writhed and I feared that my sternum would separate.
I gasp for air.
Then I was thrown abruptly to the floor.
Shackles were jammed around my ankles and the leg bar was fastened and
padlocked.
Okay.
Electric wires similar to the kind that I had hidden underneath the table was
brought forward.
I thought that the guards were going to use this to shock me,
but typical of the Vietnamese,
they didn't have anything else to use for rope and it torn the wire down from
some light fixtures.
This became the apparatus to wrap me up.
It was first tied to the manacles than thrown over my shoulder and at last
secure to the shackles around my ankles.
Guards forced a bamboo Paul under the wire and started rotating it so that the
wire contracted,
bringing my wrists up high on my back and drawing my face completely to my
ankles.
Oh was a human pretzel,
a Tea Cup with arms for a handle and the rest of my distorted body for the ball
circulation was impaired throughout my limbs,
making them extremely painful to the touch.
The guards apparently drugged,
exhibited wide and glassy eyes.
They maliciously kicked me in the sides,
the limbs,
the back and the head giggling and having a great time.
They picked me up a few feet from the floor,
dropped me since I was on my side.
Most of the time they especially enjoyed standing on my head symbolically
victorious.
The rubber tire saw sandals tore at my ear,
my face already target for abusers,
repeatedly subjected to fisticuffs and kicks.
I remember staring at the floor and seeing my tears dropping the pools of blood
coming from my nose.
Okay.
The louder I screamed,
the more they flailed.
After about an hour,
the junior officer returned.
You've talked now.
Yes.
The guards loosened the wires and ropes.
Blood rushed back into my veins with knifing pain.
What airplane you fly.
Okay.
I hesitated a moment at the thought,
well,
they know the airplane I'm flying because it's so ridiculous to undergo such
torture for information.
They already have the f four B,
that
part right there.
I mean where you hesitate for a moment and then you say to yourself,
okay,
these guys shot me down in an f four which crashed into this patty and they know
exactly what I was flying.
This is not make sense for me to get this kind of abuse and torture for
something that they already know.
And when you came to that conclusion,
how did you,
did you,
was it pretty well you're feeling comfortable with it in your mind?
When you came to collegiate luck,
this is stupid.
No,
I was really never comfortable at all in that.
I felt very guilty.
I was afraid.
Oh really?
It was very remorseful that I had not been as strong as I wanted to be.
And,
uh,
and through the,
you know,
the first several months of that experience.
So,
uh,
I felt like,
um,
I felt very guilty about having given up,
you know,
fighter pilots are not supposed to give up,
we were by and the code of conduct,
of course,
name,
rank,
serial number,
date of birth.
Um,
I flew over this,
the enemy thinking that I was strong enough and that was good enough.
And um,
and,
and suddenly I was thrust into this situation and I even wondered,
would I,
would I ever be able to go back to my country?
Can I face might fellow fighter pilots that were stronger and tougher?
And
I found out that,
that,
that feeling across the board,
every,
every pow that I ever ran into felt guilty.
And some guys even considered suicide because they felt like they could,
they could never live with the guilt of having given up.
And it was,
it was quite a revelation to me when I finally made contact with another
prisoner and confessed to this guy,
I remember that my first contact and I said,
I said,
uh,
oh,
I need to confess something to you.
And when I tell you what I've done,
you may not want to communicate with me.
You may hate me.
And if our roles were reversed,
I would probably hate you if you did what I did because I assumed that I was the
only one that ever gave in.
And so he said,
this is Bob Shoemaker.
He said,
what do,
what do you do,
plum?
I said,
well,
I,
I broke.
Uh,
I tried to be strong,
but I,
I wasn't,
I broke in his response and,
and we're,
we're talking on a,
on the end of a wire,
we tugging on a wire to communicate with each other with this secret code that I
had,
that he had just taught me.
He said,
hell,
everybody broke.
He said,
there's not a man in this camp that is as strong as he wanted to be said,
so get over yourself,
you know,
and that was a,
it was a great revelation in my mind,
you know,
to know that I wasn't the only one that had given him
as you,
you continue this and
again,
I,
you're,
you might've felt like you broke at this point,
but there's still some unbelievable spirit that you show.
And I'm going back to the book around the courtyard in a nearby room.
My copilot copilot,
Gary Anderson,
was undergoing about the same treatment as soon as I heard him exploding
obscenities.
I knew he was near.
Hey Gary,
you all right?
I called the guards are remedial on top,
immediately on top,
kicking and striking.
Gary heard me and yelled back.
It was four years later that I came across a pow who had been a sell close to
ours at the time.
He said,
boy,
that was one of the craziest things I ever heard you yelling.
Hey Gary,
are you all right?
Bang.
Crunch fid.
Fine.
How about you?
Smack crash.
Crack.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
you eventually get,
they're going to take you in and kind of parade you in front of Vietnamese
people.
And
going back to the book,
the officer briefed me once more.
I was to walk with my head down until he gave me the command,
let people see face the guards,
remove the cops,
and I pumped my hands and torch my shoulders to restore circulation.
The guards carefully directed me to the door,
removing the blindfold and warned me not to look around.
They then prodded me down the hallway lined with photographers and journalists,
a group composed of orientals and a few Caucasians with the officer at my side.
I walked out of the building onto the patio where a battery of motion cameras
started worrying.
The officer shouted to me,
let people see face slowly and deliberately.
I looked up staring blankly into space,
bowed deeply to the cameras and lowered my head.
I was uneasy about this entire charade,
feeling a combination of resentment and embarrassment at being featured as a
sides show attraction.
And what I didn't know at the time was it was Holcim man's birthday.
And,
uh,
so that was part of the celebration,
was I was being presented to the president of their country,
those a birthday gift popping out of a cake.
And,
uh,
and the good news was that,
that I was,
I was in the media that they were taking pictures of me.
And so after a few months,
uh,
my family saw those pictures.
Right.
And,
uh,
and so that was the good news about being shot down on the 19th of May.
So that was the first indication that people knew that you were actually okay.
Right.
Or You were alive.
Maybe not.
Okay.
A strong word didn't mean to say,
okay,
we're alive.
The,
uh,
the,
the picture that was taken and transferred to my family has me with my eyes
closed in my face was pretty well swollen.
And my little brother thought that I was dead.
He thought that was a picture of a dead man.
And so,
um,
but,
uh,
but I think most people thought,
yeah,
no,
he,
he's alive.
So
you actually get,
how'd you get stabbed?
Bayoneted you were about to fall or something?
Actually I was,
I was,
uh,
being prodded to walk faster by these guys.
And I was,
I was hurting at the time,
you know,
I was injured from the,
from the ejection,
and I wasn't able to walk very fast.
Then I was blindfolded as well.
And so I hit it.
I hit a Rut in the road and these guards with their bayonet fixed behind me stab
me in the,
in the thigh.
And so that was in fact,
that was the worst wound that I had.
And it festered for months because I had no medical care.
Um,
and um,
but I,
I never really knew if it was intentional or it was accidental,
but that was a,
that was how I got that wound.
Now you get back in and they're going to give you,
they give you the rules for the first time that you're supposed to follow and
the,
the guy reads him to your,
and I'm just gonna,
I gotta read these roles because,
uh,
I think they give a good indication as to what you were facing.
Here we go back to the book.
You are the blackest criminal that this country has ever seen,
but do do the lenient humane policy of the Vietnamese people.
If you follow regulations,
you live in peace regulation number one,
criminals must give full and complete answers to questions asked by Vietnamese
guard or officer.
Number two,
criminals must make no noise in room number three.
Criminals must keep room clean and neat and must not mark rooms so graciously
given by Vietnamese people.
Number four,
criminals must get up and go to bed at sound of Gong.
Number five,
criminals must get under bed when imperialist aggressor bomb and strafe our
sovereign country.
Number six criminals must say bowel cow when they want.
Ask anything.
Number seven,
criminals must go only in area that guard orders when they go outside of room.
Number eight,
criminals must bow to every Vietnamese guards,
officers and people.
Number nine,
criminals must not bring anything into room from outside.
Number 10,
criminals must not communicate with or look at other criminals in any other room
or outside with minor variations.
These were the rules for the next six years.
Big One was the communication.
They didn't want you guys talking to each other.
No,
they didn't.
And uh,
they did all of that they possibly could do to keep us from communicating.
But we got very clever and we,
uh,
had a lot of ways to communicate.
Now,
you spent some time in solitary confinement and here we go back to book.
During this period of solitary confinement,
I had much time to think from the start.
I established a definite schedule for personal reflection and appraisal.
This included a two hour worship service in the morning and a similar one in the
evening.
I spent much time praying,
talking informally with God and recalling as many scriptures verses and Bible
stories as I could.
I also revive the words and tunes to songs from a Tennessee Ernie Ford album
that I'd enjoyed on the Kitty Hawk.
Once in a while,
I would start humming too loudly and a guard would bang his rifle against the
door.
I spent more and more time thinking about intangibles.
The purpose for living ethics,
the supernatural faith,
pride.
Because the tangibles which I had identified with were no longer present my
aircraft,
my ship,
my personal possessions.
This was the onset of a thorough reexamination of my,
often these intricate thought processes ended in slumber.
One of the interesting things that it really most difficult to understand is how
we had nothing going on.
Um,
you know what I mean?
The,
the,
the average American has hundreds of thousands of inputs,
everyday colors and sounds and smells and touch and all of these things.
Uh,
and when you're in a little prison cell,
especially if you're in solitary confinement,
you know,
you might,
you might hear a bird,
you know,
and then that's delightful.
That's a big deal,
you know,
to hear a bird and nothing else.
So,
uh,
again,
the good news and the bad news is your mind goes internal and you start,
you have to,
you have to create things,
uh,
on your own.
And so you think about these intangible things and you go back through your life
and,
uh,
and you think about the things that sustain life and why we are here,
because there's nothing else to do.
Did you put some kind of structure around your thoughts?
It seems like you people might have a tendency just to let their mind wander and
maybe it wanders into places they don't want it to wander into.
No,
there was a lot of structure to it.
And uh,
in fact,
one of the things I did was to go back through my life to the very first memory
that I ever had at three years old in Lee Compton,
Kansas,
when my grandmother came through and wanted everybody to,
to go with her well.
And I remember that date.
And then I went from that to the day that I was shot down and tried to remember
every book I've ever read,
every friend had ever met,
every girl I'd ever dated,
every a teacher,
books,
movies,
uh,
experiences.
And it took me about,
as I recall,
maybe three months working pretty hard on,
on that,
that total autobiography in my mind.
And after that,
then I would continue to go back through those individual days and try to
remember something else.
You know,
a different colored that I'd forgotten or a different person that was in the
room and whenever I would,
when I would discover something that I hadn't discovered the first three months,
it was like,
it was like meeting an old friend.
I could think about that one person or that one book or whatever,
you know,
for an entire day.
And so it was just,
it was a way of,
of,
um,
of using that time in making the time go by,
uh,
by working our minds.
Did you somehow catalog the days in your mind?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It was a,
it was a chronology.
and,
and most everybody did that and a lot of guys did it much better than I,
they could tell you,
you know,
what was going on this day,
last year,
the year before and the year they,
you know,
they,
uh,
they could remember everything and had it all packed away.
But yes,
it was very well categorized.
You finally get some pair of pants,
a couple pairs of pants,
a couple shirts,
some underwear,
undershirts toothbrush and some soap and you are going to use it for the first
time I stripped and with my little drinking cup,
douse myself with water lathered with my new bar of soap and rinsed,
shedding a two week layer of grime and sweat.
Then I shaved using a double edged razor which had no handle at last.
I was clean,
no itchy beard,
no Rican body.
I put on my new clothes and wondered what impressions I would now make on the
newly captured POW [inaudible] dressed in fresh habla mint.
I experienced a sublime physical and mental catharsis.
Even the pain of my wounds seem to wash away with the filth.
15 minutes later I was back in my cell reinspired to outlast any Vietnamese
endeavor to debase me.
The door opened.
I waited for something to happen and then in the doorway sauntered in a tall man
back hunched and forehead,
deeply lined.
He studied me with uncertain eyes and American,
another American.
I rushed to the door as quickly as I could and grasped his hand the hand,
which was completely numb from inadequate sir circulation at the elbows high.
I said,
Charlie pawn.
So now you're living
dealt with another American.
I am.
Kay Russell was shut down in the same day I was.
And so he and I were,
uh,
he was my first roommate.
Um,
and,
and uh,
you know,
I was,
uh,
in the same cell with a lot of different guys and they moved us around a lot,
about every six months it moves around,
but they would give us different roommates every few months or take them all
away.
And that was in solitary confinement again.
And uh,
we never really knew why,
but we assume that it was tried to destroy any fraternization with the guards
and try to disrupt any unity within the prisoners.
And so,
um,
so the,
in fact sometimes there's a little bit difficult to describe exactly what it was
like because we were in different camps and different cells and you were
different guys for the entire six years.
But didn't you,
do you like it when you got a new roommate?
Cause it's like a new,
you kind of explained the,
it's like now you have a bunch of stuff to talk about what this person
absolutely.
Absolutely.
It was a,
it was glorious,
you know,
to find the,
uh,
because,
you know,
he of course had all of the stories and he had the movies that he could tell you
about and the things that he had learned and,
uh,
that he could teach you.
So yeah,
no,
it was,
it was wonderful.
Now that would last for maybe a few months until you ran out of the things and
then it became almost like a marriage,
you know,
where you've got those,
those periods of time,
money,
mood periods of,
yeah,
exactly.
Well the fact of matter is you couldn't,
in some of those cells,
you couldn't be more than eight or 10 feet away from a guy 24,
seven for months and months and months at a time.
Right.
And so little things start to bug Ya,
you know,
and uh,
Eh,
not the least of which was a w w was our toilet.
The toilet was a two gallon bucket in the corner.
And uh,
lots of times it was rusted out at the top with no lid and it was just quite a,
you know,
it,
it stunk to high heaven a lot of the cases.
And um,
and it was quite an irritant.
Yeah.
You guys established a routine once you got in there and you know,
there's a whole chapter in the book called routine and you're waking up at six
30 in the morning,
you're doing prayer at that time,
you're at seven o'clock,
you're,
you're practicing piano,
which I like and right.
And you're practicing piano.
And I was just from memory.
You,
had you ever played piano before?
I hadn't.
I had not.
Now,
what I did know was that my span from my pinky to my thumb was not,
it was a,
I could span nine notes on a piano.
And so I laid out a keyboard on my board bed and the new where the black keys
were.
And I had played in the band,
uh,
and uh,
and also played guitar.
So I knew a little bit about chords and scales and that kind of thing.
And I thought,
well,
I've always wanted to play the piano and all,
now's my chance.
This piece of wood looks good to me.
Yes,
this,
this a work.
And then at eight o'clock you're doing pushups and sit ups and leg lifts and
whatever else,
or you're doing some,
some physical training and then you have school,
the school bell rings at 9:30 AM and you guys are,
you guys are learning and teaching each other,
whatever you can possibly teach each other.
Whatever subject you were good at,
you are going to teach.
We did.
And it was serious stuff.
As a matter of fact,
when we got home,
University of Maryland gave us credit for what we had,
you know,
the,
the courses we had taught,
you know,
without books or paper or powerpoints or instructors or professors or anybody
because we were so intent on using that time for something of value.
And,
uh,
and,
and these guys,
uh,
most of them smarter than than I would go back through their minds and recapture
all of the subjects that they had learned.
One of the guy,
Joe Milligan,
I was with him,
uh,
I don't know the first few months,
I guess,
and he taught a course,
uh,
and um,
chemistry,
no biology.
It was biology.
And I'd never taken a course in biology.
And I was very interested and in his course lasted about a week.
Um,
and,
and that's all he knew.
But Joe and I live with him for awhile.
We're laid back on his rack,
about an,
uh,
an hour a day and just think about biology.
And after being there for six years,
he,
his course lasted six months and he knew everything protozoas the metazoan was.
And all of this just because that was back there in his mind.
He was able to recall that.
I recall that in deep,
deep enough.
And it is amazing.
You know what,
what's back in there and your human brain.
It's,
and we found that out.
If you think about something long enough and hard enough and again you don't
have these distractions of,
of everyday life that uh,
there's an awful lot stored back in there.
Yeah.
I had to bring this one up too because you talked about how you didn't have
PowerPoint or whatever.
You'd have pens and chalkboards and here you go.
Often in my dreams,
I must admit,
I envisioned leaving the Noi,
Hilton going home,
looking for and finding a brand new yellow pencil and bringing it back to myself
or I would dream of entering shops containing nothing but rows and rows of
pencils.
I've never since taking a pencil for granted,
that's,
you know,
we take so much for granted.
I mean,
didn't take so much for granted and to think about that right there and what,
what power a pencil.
If you have the power to take notes,
the power to create the power to draw the power to write this incredible power
comes from this little thing that we just gaffe off.
Like it's meaningless.
That's right.
And for you to have that much appreciation for it,
that you would dream about it at night.
True.
It's incredible.
Uh,
10 o'clock you'd eat.
And what was the food?
Was the food you're eating?
Rice balls?
Yeah,
mostly rice.
Uh,
that was the mainstay.
You had,
um,
you know,
you get a small bowl of rice twice a day,
looked about 10 o'clock once about two o'clock in the afternoon,
and then you had a 20 hour stretch with nothing to eat.
Uh,
sometimes they'd give you a bowl of broth in.
Sometimes it would be a,
some kind of vegetable turnips or,
uh,
weeds of some kind when we call sewer soup.
You couldn't identify this stuff,
but I didn't need it.
You know,
there was not enough meat,
uh,
to put in a coffee cup for a year,
you know,
we,
there really was no,
there was no meat of any variety.
How much,
how much did you weigh when you got out?
Uh,
I weighed about 140 when I came home,
but they fatten this up before we came home.
And I figure most of the time I was there about 115 pounds.
Did you,
uh,
ever was the hunger,
did the hunger go away?
Did you or you just grinding hunger or did you just get used to it?
Uh,
it went away for the most part,
you know,
after,
I don't know,
four or five months,
um,
your,
your stomach sort of shrinks and when you know that there's nothing else to eat,
um,
and so you know,
that they,
in all fairness,
they gave us enough to keep us alive and,
um,
uh,
and,
and so that,
you know,
and rice is a pretty perfect food.
This is unpolished rice.
It wasn't the uncle Ben's and we have today and a,
and there's a lot,
there's,
there's protein in there and there's nutrients in the rice.
So that kept me alive.
Yeah.
At dusk you guys would have
showtime and people would do what you're talking about describing everything.
And every movie they've ever seen,
every book they've ever read and all that.
And uh,
you mentioned in here that in the beginning of confinement movies that would get
described or created cause people were creating movies to write in their head.
Yes,
yes.
And they went from PG to triple x overtime.
So did anybody come out and,
and execute on some of these ideas that they had?
Is there any way that came out and said,
yeah,
I thought of this movie or this book?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
In fact,
Sarah guys had great plans when one guy was a farmer and he had planned a pig
farm.
That was a,
that was his whole thing.
Um,
and he did,
he came back in the,
I live with a guy by the name of Danny Glenn,
who was an architecture student at the University of Oklahoma.
And,
uh,
Dan and I were together for a lot of years and he dreamed about building this
home.
And,
uh,
and that's all I thought about was building this dream house.
And he had several little things about this home that we're very peculiar.
One of them was,
uh,
as the sunlight would come through the top of the wall around our prison,
the wall was kept with Barb wire in electrical wire and broken glass.
The glass was from bottles.
It was a various colors.
And in one particular cell that Dan and I were in,
the sun would come through the glass,
the colored glass,
and on to,
uh,
this,
this tank of water,
and then reflect up under the eaves of our fast roof and into ourselves.
So we had all these colors and it was a beautiful thing,
you know,
was a kaleidoscope of colors.
And so he designed a house,
any figure,
this whole thing out,
you know,
with the,
with the asthma of the sun and in all of this stuff and how he was going to do
this.
But,
uh,
and he would lay this out and he would draw on the concrete floor with a piece
of brick.
And,
uh,
he was a great artist,
you know,
the,
the guy could,
could design all this stuff.
And,
uh,
and of course,
you know,
he wanted me to be involved in this and in bore me to tears.
And he's Charlie.
What color do you think my bathroom ought to be?
I Dunno man.
I don't know.
No,
no,
no.
Charlie green or blue?
I don't know.
Green and green.
Okay.
So we,
we get home in,
had about a year after we,
I was living in Kansas and that he was in Oklahoma and he called me up.
Charlie,
I got something to show you.
And so I had a little airplane at the time when I flew down to Norman,
Oklahoma and he picked me up at the airport and we drove outside of town from
about a quarter of a mile away.
I saw this house that I recognize,
but I'd never been in Norman,
Oklahoma and I,
I swear I could have walked in that house and,
and touched any faucet or any light switch,
you know,
the whole points because it was exactly as he had decided the prison.
So I went to the bathroom and it was blue.
He had gone back,
you know,
he had built it from a building materials that he had remembered and over the
years that we were there they changed and so there were some of the,
it was not available and so he went to these old lumber yards and he would find
the building materials that he had planned this house with and use those to
build his house.
And it was Greg.
But yeah,
a lot of the guys,
a lot of the guys wanted to sail around the world.
You know a lot of us navy guys,
we had a sale and,
and that was the big fantasy was to take a sailing trip around the world in two
or three of the guys actually did that when they came home.
Yeah.
Awesome.
The guards,
some of the guards were pretty sadistic and here we go back to the,
probably the most sadistic practice of all was a game involving mice or puppies.
Guards would douse them with gasoline and set them on fire and turn them loose
to squeal and scurry and search a relief from the heat.
Then the soldiers would chase them with sticks playing polo with their live
fireballs until the little animals blackened and died.
So you had some serious sad status.
Yeah,
we just do an evil things and you say you didn't see anything book magazine,
newspaper Lyrics or song written speech,
any billboard or anything while you were there.
That wasn't just a hundred percent propaganda.
That's true.
You know,
uh,
their music doesn't talk about love except for love of hace man and love of
their country and dedication to that,
um,
at,
it's really incredible how they just fill the minds of their people with this
propaganda.
And uh,
you know,
you tell somebody long enough and loud enough and they believe it and that's,
that was the whole,
that was the whole country.
The one point you got this propaganda newspaper and it's the front page headline
was that there's been a revolution in rice planting technique and you were
thinking yourself,
oh man,
they must have invented some big machine that can like plan all the rice and now
they don't have to be out there on that.
You're doing the manual labor in the fields.
And here's the actual article.
For 4,000 years,
the Vietnamese people had been laboring,
sweating,
and toiling in the modern water of rice patties.
We've discovered a revolutionary method of planting rice.
Through extensive research.
We have found that instead of grasping the rice sprouts and planting them with
the palm of the hand facing downward is much more efficient to plant the rice
sprouts with the palm of the hand facing upward.
So there's,
there's the propaganda coming at you and there's the advancement of the,
you know,
them trying to tell the people how we're moving forward in the world.
And that was another thing that surprised me or it didn't surprise me,
but how,
what their,
their understanding,
you know,
they're,
they're brainwashed and their understanding of what American culture was like.
And when you'd say,
well,
yeah,
I have a car and I have an air conditioner.
To them that was just unbelievable because the only people that could afford
that in Vietnam war,
this was the state itself.
True.
And they assume that if he had a car,
uh,
you could carry pigs or chickens or something in your car.
I guess that was the whole purpose of any kind of transportation was a haul
something around.
And,
uh,
and they,
you know,
they were really surprised that you could actually
just get in the car and go wherever you want it to go.
And they also fought that a third of Americans were starving to death.
So that's,
you know,
something to think about.
Always when you deal with these countries where people are being indoctrinated
and be with,
they're being fed information from the state,
it's going to be,
it's going to be lower eyes and you,
you,
you can't be surprised when they believe something like that.
You just have to say what they believe.
How do we reeducate them?
I went back to Vietnam,
uh,
first time in 43 years.
I hadn't been back.
And,
uh,
a lot of things had changed,
you know,
I mean,
they still call themselves a communist country,
but oh,
by the way,
capitalism is alive and well,
but the propaganda is still exists there.
And,
uh,
and I took my family with me,
my wife and three of our four kids.
Uh,
and in the 11 days that I was there,
I never met anyone.
And I was at,
you know,
it was to embassy.
I spoke to the students at the university.
I spoke to cab drivers and waitresses and anybody.
And they,
it really,
really nice people and very,
very nice to me.
But nobody knew that Americans had been tortured in the Vietnam War.
And in fact,
it was just the opposite.
They all would tell you that we got better treatment than the soldiers did and
better medical care than the soldiers did.
And so,
and in fact,
and in one of the,
uh,
one of the last days I was there,
I ran into a lady in the park selling card postcards and she was missing a one
leg and she was about my age.
And so I sort of piece this thing together and,
uh,
she said,
one of my postcard,
well,
I'll buy a postcard,
but I want to hear your story.
Sit Down on this park bench and then,
uh,
tell me your story.
And she did.
I said,
how'd you lose your leg?
She said,
linebacker to linebacker to was the codename for the [inaudible] bombings that
ended the war in night in the Christmas of 1972 at,
but it was a secret code knee,
you know,
and for her to say she didn't call it an air raid or a bomb or anything else,
just call called our linebacker to,
and it was aren't,
you know,
that was our pilot jargon,
not her jargon.
And uh,
I said,
uh,
w what,
what,
what was the date?
She said 24,
December,
1972.
So I knew that she wasn't lying to me.
She said,
um,
be 52.
Oh yeah.
Well,
so we talked for maybe 30 minutes on that park bench and she spoke very good
English.
And,
uh,
and at one point I said to her,
you speak excellent English.
You could be an interpreter,
you can be a guide.
Why are you out here making a living selling postcards in a park?
She said,
oh my,
my country would never give me a permit because I'm an invalid.
Ah,
man,
what a country.
And,
and then I said,
well,
um,
uh,
do you know about the,
the museums?
Uh,
oh yeah.
I know all about the museums and the Hanoi Hilton Museum.
See,
they've made a museum out of my old prison camp.
The Hanoi Hilton is now a museum.
And I said,
well,
how were the prisoners treated at the museum?
All of they were treated great.
They had great food.
They played volleyball,
they had ping pong.
I said,
how do you know this?
She said,
oh,
documentaries.
The government shows us documentaries.
And so she finally figured out that I was about her age and she said,
were you a pilot?
I said,
yeah,
it was a pilot.
She said,
be 52.
I said,
no.
I flew f four phantoms.
Oh,
so were were you flying?
Uh,
on the 24th of December of 1972 I said,
no,
I was right here with you.
I was in the Hanoi Hilton and I was being tortured.
She said,
no,
that's impossible.
That it can't possibly be true.
I could not convince this lady that I would,
that I or anybody else there.
So the propaganda is alive and well.
They keep continue to tell that people the lies and uh,
and,
and the folks who have no way of figuring it out,
you know,
it's,
uh,
another thing that,
that you point out in the book on that culture or that,
that system of government back to the book,
the Vietnamese rarely exerted themselves.
Why should they,
if they were gonna get a meal at all,
they'd eat regardless of whether they worked for it or not.
They didn't worry.
They didn't have to,
the state was responsible for their welfare as well as their guidance.
Even the upkeep of state property was not their problem.
So
they're scary thing when
it really is,
when,
you know,
when folks are indoctrinated to that level and,
um,
but it's so prevalent,
you know,
uh,
and,
and they tried to do the same thing with us.
Yeah.
They tried to brainwash shots in,
it
was more important to,
you were kind of worried about that too in the beginning,
right?
Like you fall,
it was something you needed to be concerned about and then you saw how
ridiculous.
Yeah.
And you know,
they,
uh,
they used a lot of,
of the Russian,
the military equipment,
but they never invited the Russians in to try to brainwash us.
And we felt very,
very happy about that because they're brainwashing techniques were so silly.
And,
uh,
you know,
they would tell us this unbelievable things that,
that we laughed at
where you thought the Russians would do a better job.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure they would have,
but more important than the rice we ate or the water we drink.
And every prison cell I was in,
the first thing they put in there was a speaker.
And,
um,
you know,
lots of,
lots of the prison camps didn't have any electricity at all,
but they had speakers and they were well above our reach,
so we couldn't turn them off or adjust the volume.
And,
um,
several times a day they would come on with the propaganda and telling us how
bad we were and how terrible our country was and how wonderful they were.
And um,
in it,
it was pretty easy to turn these guys off,
you know,
just to ignore the uh,
the broadcast.
But it was also very concerning to see that that's the way they way they
indoctrinate their own people.
Horrible.
You,
you talked about a little bit earlier you talked about the communication and,
and what that was all about and you had this lift the first time you were in
your cell,
you hear a little scraping and eventually you go over and it's little wire and
eventually note comes through it.
And here we go back to the book,
had a piece of toilet paper tied to it.
I unfolded it and found these words,
memorize code,
eat note.
The code was easier to memorize.
Then the note was to eat.
But
I did both.
I rechecked the door,
sat back down on the honey bucket and talked on the wire.
The code was a series of togs which represented letters of the alphabet and
it's,
it's basically a five by five code a,
And that is how you guys communicated.
And that had to be,
how long does it take to have a conversation with that code?
Cause you give,
you know,
one,
two tugs to go down and then one,
two,
three tugs to go across.
How long does it take when you have these conversations?
Must have taken a long time.
Well that's true.
But that was a beauty of it because that's all we had was time.
And that was a very good way of,
uh,
of whiling away.
The hours is tugging on,
the wires are tapping on walls and uh,
or,
or sneezing and wheezing.
We had all kinds of ways to communicate and uh,
Eh,
and we took great pride in our communication effort and the sneezing and reasons
that just was it more,
how did the sneezing and wheezing,
coughing,
it was the same kind of thing,
you know?
Uh,
it was all based around this five by five Matrix of the alphabet.
And so a cough would,
wouldn't be one.
A sneeze would be to weeds would be three on and so forth.
So that,
so that two sounds would equal a letter.
And we use this in a lot of different ways.
If a guy was outside chopping wood for a fire for instance,
and he would chop in this code,
chop,
chop.
And it was what we called it,
we called it in a radio station because everybody could hear it.
And uh,
and so,
um,
if,
if a new guy came into the camp and we knew who the president was,
you know,
lots of,
we did,
we had no information at all or new,
uh,
who won the world series for instance,
why it was really big deal,
you know,
to get out there and chop the wood and the radio station and until the entire
camp,
who was the president?
The,
the guards ever catch on to that five by five code.
Yes.
Uh,
occasionally in a couple of guys were tortured to,
to reveal the code,
but they could,
but they were,
it was really interesting because they were so uncoordinated that they couldn't
replicate the code and they,
on several cases,
they tried to trick us and they would empty out a sale.
And they would,
uh,
go into that cell and try to tap on the wall or tug on the wire in the code.
And we knew immediately,
you know,
that it wasn't an American.
Uh,
and you guys would get,
like I said is interesting.
You count you,
you laid out two things.
At first the Vietnamese were like pretty much okay with stealing and so you
wouldn't get punished for stealing that bad.
But the communication thing is what they is what they would definitely punish
you for.
Yup.
True.
Yeah.
That,
uh,
I mean that's the same thing.
I mean,
when we capture prisoners overseas,
we don't want to talk to each other.
We'd separate them and you don't want them to talk to each other.
And at some point you started getting letters and receiving letters.
And how did that change the environment?
Well,
I'm in a,
first of all,
we were just overjoyed to see that our,
that our families,
you know,
that my wife,
uh,
was,
was okay and um,
and that they knew that we were alive.
And so it was,
you know,
it was a wonderful connection that we made.
Now we,
we call them letters,
but actually they were postcards and I'm in,
they were highly edited.
Uh,
it began with a postcard is we're just blanked out.
And then the Vietnamese decided that that's not good enough.
They actually would cut out certain words and so he had a postcard of six lines
and maybe of the six lines,
there might be a 15 words,
they would just cut out with a pair of scissors so that sometimes you really
couldn't figure it out what they were trying to say.
But you know,
that the fact that,
uh,
that was in the handwriting of a loved one,
was,
was very comforting.
And yet those bastards,
and I use that term very specifically for this situation,
the dear John Letters,
they'd leave.
Those components are good to go and turn those over.
And you know,
it's,
you say bastards for that.
Is that kind of behavior from bastards?
Yeah.
They were quick to,
uh,
to tell us that our wives had filed for divorce or that,
you know,
our parents had died or that any bad news.
Uh,
they were,
they were very quick to promote.
Yeah.
The chain of command that you guys,
you know,
here you are in this prison camp and you guys all,
you figured out,
you realize we need to have a chain of command and you put that structure into
place.
And
when you did that,
did that Kinda,
I mean,
it seems like it would have,
it seems like that gave you guys so much strength as an,
as a group to get in the chain of command,
to organize yourselves.
It seemed like that gave you guys so much strength and fortitude as you,
as you were there.
It was absolutely our survival,
uh,
was our chain of command.
Um,
what,
what you don't know.
And reading my book because they're only happened two or three years ago.
A study was done of all of the combatants of Vietnam,
of all the million and a half people that were exposed to that war,
30.6% had PTSD.
Almost a third of the combatants in Vietnam,
post traumatic stress disorder of the prisoners of war.
4% of us that PTSD,
and it's primarily the guys who were shot down near the end of the war were only
prisoners for a few weeks or a month or two.
And what we really believe,
and this is spelled out in another book called lessons from the Hanoi Hilton,
which was written about,
uh,
two years ago,
lessons from the Hanoi Hilton explains that the reason why we came back and her
in such great shape is because of the unit to the we had in the leadership that
we had in the prison camps because of the 591 guys came home and of the 591 and
they thought we'd be in baskets.
They thought we'd be vegetables.
They had our families brief to institutionalize us for the rest of our lives.
That's what they thought was coming home from prison camp.
And what can you expect from 591 guys?
We've produced 17 generals,
seven admirals.
Most of us retired his senior grade military officers.
We have doctors and lawyers and preachers and teachers and bishops and judges
where a bunch of congressmen,
two United States senators,
two ambassadors.
We have a vice presidential candidate,
a president or candidate,
my old flight instructor,
John Mccain.
And they're telling us today where it healthier mentally and physically then if
we hadn't been shot down.
And it was primarily because of the leadership,
the chain of command that we had over there,
the unity that we found and the purpose that that's what the leadership in the
prison camp did for us.
Uh,
Jim Stockdale was our senior SRO,
senior residing officer in a prison camp for a long time and he said,
we are no longer victims of circumstance beyond our control.
We are not on the defensive here.
We are military men,
we are combatants and we will pursue this war until our last breath.
And so what he did,
what that did was it gave us a reason to live,
a reason to be a reason to unify.
And the,
the,
the way we fought the war from the prison camp was to try to deny them any
propaganda.
Because as you,
as you've already said,
Jocko,
that this,
the propaganda was the mainstay.
I mean,
it was,
that was numero uno in their world was,
was propagandizing.
And they felt that,
that they,
that they could use us to tell the rest of the world how wonderful communism was
and how terrible capitalism was.
And now they were right,
we were wrong.
And so they would,
they would,
uh,
force guys to make tapes or write letters to the antiwar element and,
you know,
proclaim the,
the,
the wonderful nature of communism.
And so our job was to defend against this.
And,
uh,
and so we set up all
kinds of,
of methods so that we would deny them any propaganda or even in some cases,
we would even go farther than to not deny.
The propaganda,
we would use their tools against them and that we would tell the world that,
oh,
by the way,
we are being tortured and oh by the way,
you know this,
you know,
these guys are attacking our neighbor in south Vietnam.
And so,
so the,
so that was the big effort and,
and um,
you know,
like I said,
this whole thing,
you just can't came out a few years ago that this was the big reason that we did
so well and that we're so healthy mentally and physically to today was because
we had this chain of command.
And on top of that,
and this is what I've really,
one of the big points I wanted to talk about today was what you're just hitting
on is that people have this idea that the military chain of command is this
rigid structure and that's why it survives.
And that's what the,
but you guys were put into a position that it was,
yes,
there's a military chain of command just like I had in the seal teams.
And if you,
if you think in the seal teams that I was the guy that was in charge and I was
barking orders and everyone was following everything I said to.
It's like,
no,
it wasn't like that.
It's a much more collaborative deal and you,
you and this really became clear one section of the book here.
I'm going to,
I'm going to read that.
What you were dealing with and how challenging this leadership position was for
the people that were,
we're leading,
so here we going back to the book,
making sure that everyone was on our team was the first of many objectives.
Understanding the rules of the game was the second.
It was assumed that all of us had a basic knowledge of the military discipline
and the code of conduct.
This code,
a very general document was open to many interpretations.
How we construed the code often depending on the severity of the situation,
no longer could we pick up a telephone and call the Pentagon for advice.
The broad spectrum of the code divided the men in at least two groups.
Those who were disciplinarians by nature and interpreted the code strictly and
those who were liberal and rendered the code loosely.
We called these two groups,
the tough guys and the softies,
but this is this.
The key part right here,
softy was not derogatory.
The name simply indicated a different approach to the code.
Tough guys who referred to the line,
I will never surrender of my own freewill.
Sometimes flaunted their encourage ability and taunted the guards.
The Vietnamese answered with torture and the tough guys occasionally
relinquished more information than the softies who never committed themselves.
Regardless of our attitudes,
we were all in the same boat.
Each of us had acquiesce to the Vietnamese control to some extent,
whether accepting cigarettes are bowing to guards.
The line which separated the tough guys from the softies was often unclear.
The important thing was to display unity.
Regardless of our individual philosophies,
we clearly understood that the Vietnamese would capitalize on any chinks they
found in our armor.
Unity didn't evolve automatically.
Learning its value required from us,
such introspection and sacrifice.
How could it camp SRO appease the softies if he interpreted the code to strictly
or if he was too lax for the tough guys,
he was in an untenable position having little control over the actions of men in
other rooms.
He had excessive responsibility,
but none of the tools of authority.
No reduction of salary,
suspension of Liberty Court Marshal.
Indeed most of the fellows,
he had never seen his only association being a tap on the wall or a scribbled
message to meet this impractical setting.
The SRO wielded gentle sticks of diplomacy.
They knew we were not boots,
meaning bootcamp guys fresh out of bootcamp.
Who?
Who,
who asked how high at the command,
the jump.
We were all trained leaders who acted independently for the first few years.
The SRO is a 40 was limited to advice rather than orders.
Realizing the importance of unity we respected is this advice as the wit were in
order.
What if we refuse an order on the basis that it did not come from the commander,
but rather from five men who interpreted through our error ridden system.
What if compliance to the order brought certain torture?
We were very alone in answering these questions.
Once I received an order plumb request,
you communicate with Captain Abbot at all costs.
What did the SRO mean by at all costs?
They didn't include being caught and put in leg irons for months at a time.
So the way that that is laid out,
it reflects not just leadership in a prison camp.
I'm here to tell you it reflects leadership in every situation because the
minute that you as a leader decided that you're just going to impose your will
on other people is where you start to lose respect and people start questioning
what you're doing.
That's very true.
And I think that the way that this comes out,
and that probably is one of the reasons why,
you know,
I didn't know about the facts that you just told me about the only 4% having
PTSD.
I mean,
and obviously you rattled off all the successful pdws that came out of this
horrible situation,
but that openness,
that open mind as leaders and and as subordinates to say,
look,
I'm getting this advice right.
This is so called advice from the boss.
I respect it,
I'm going to act on it.
Not because I have to,
but because I understand the mission.
I understand we're doing
this and therefore it's not something that's being imposed on me.
It's something that I am accepting and pushing forward of my own accord.
That's a huge difference.
It truly is.
I,
but I must admit that when I first heard about this,
I was taken aback and I'm thinking,
you know,
this is really silly.
I've got some senior officer down to the end cell,
this cell block,
and he's putting more restrictions on me than it already have.
You know,
what way?
What's it going to do?
So take away my liberty card.
Throw you in the Brig.
Yeah,
I'm me to break,
um,
there,
uh,
and um,
and I had to be convinced,
you know,
that this was in our best interest.
Uh,
but,
but it,
it truly was.
And obviously that's the reason we came out as healthy as we did was because we,
we,
well,
you say it better than most discipline.
You know,
a discipline brought about freedom.
And it was kind of crazy because we were being restricted even more.
And yet because of the restriction we had unity,
which gave us the freedom.
Yeah.
And then you guys started taking the broad code of conduct and specifying it
cause you guys had so much time into these things that you called plums.
Right.
And you didn't really know what the establishment of word poems came from,
but they were,
they were detailed to tenants of how you all were going to carry yourself and
you called him plums and they were things like the order that you were going to
go home.
Um,
you know,
not aiding the Vietnamese and in whitewashed and the truths,
the resistance,
how,
what level of resistance you were going to give when you were,
when you were
interrogated,
how much resistance you were going to give with.
And retcon six was just,
you know,
military bearing.
And then Rez con one was straight up hunger strike.
That was one of the greatest displays I think,
uh,
that really affected the enemy was when they found out that when our commanding
officer of a,
of a camp could say,
okay,
rest con three,
no more bowing to the enemy.
And so throughout the camp,
in these individual cells,
you know,
there might be,
it might be 75 different cells and suddenly at the stroke of one,
one button,
you know,
nobody would bow to the guards.
And it really frightened them to know that we had that much control,
that much unity.
And it was a silly thing,
but it,
but it really felt so good that we had that,
that we had some leverage here.
And,
and the,
the other thing was that how you stayed,
you unified was by not accepting favors.
And then you had to just the dichotomy of leadership,
right?
You got to balance between,
hey,
if I can accept favor and it's gonna
help us and it's gonna make me healthier,
it's going to,
then I should probably do it.
But then they put this,
then the commander,
the SRO would put a restriction or a reasonable timeframe.
So this was a classic example cause I already talked about how,
how,
how in love you were with pencils at this point.
At some point you got a pencil,
somehow you've got to put,
they gave you a pencil and you know the word spread that you guys had a pencil.
And the,
the,
the report or the,
the direction came back was,
okay,
you have 30 days to get more pencils so we're all equal.
Or you got to give the pencil back and you didn't get any more pencils and you
had to give that pencil back.
Yup.
That's,
but that you can see how when you,
uh,
how unified you are and how,
just like you said,
that shows the,
the,
the guards and the camp leaders,
hey,
we are a unified,
but you can't break us.
You can't give,
you can't give somebody some special help and not give it to everyone.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
Now you started talking about this a little earlier and I had to do a little bit
deeper on it because I think it hits a parting message,
right?
So when you talk about living with somebody and how when you're living with
somebody and the furthest you can get away from him is eight feet.
That's sometimes I feel like this with echo and we're,
you know,
we're not going to live with this guy,
but sitting in this pod gasping for air and you start saying,
okay,
that's good.
What,
what things start to grind on you and irritate you.
So whether they were exercising,
you get a guy that's going to exercise while you're trying to sleep,
where you get a guy that's snores,
which if you've ever dealt with somebody that snores,
made,
can't help,
but they don't even know that they sound like a chainsaw in your room and your
deal with you might get roomed up with somebody that snores every single night.
And the worst thing about somebody that snores is when you start thinking that
it bothers you,
it bothers you.
Even write pacing.
Pacing was another thing that would,
you know,
I'm gonna just could get up and pace and hey man,
just sit down.
So all these things,
some pow ate rice,
a grain at a time,
a grain at a time.
And you know,
like on all these little,
these little,
I guess these little idiosyncrasies,
right?
And what are you eventually said was,
I'm going to take those 80 oh secrecies that bothers me about you and I'm going
to take the blame on myself.
I shouldn't be bothered by this.
And I'm the one that can't let it bother me.
And that is a huge difference to what most people do,
which is,
hey,
it's all about me and if you're bothering me,
you need to change.
And you're all,
his attitude was,
no,
you know what?
My attitudes,
you don't need to change.
I need to change.
I need to become more accepting of the way you are.
That's a big deal that you can make that transition in your life and can be a
much happier first.
That's true.
And I'm,
I'm still trying
eats.
It's one of those things where it really is a game changer because now you know
it's extreme ownership,
right?
I'm not going to blame everything on you for annoying me.
I'm going to take it on myself.
And then sometimes you would,
you'd have something that really,
like maybe you couldn't sleep and now you've got to talk to somebody else and
have,
have an indirect conversation.
Instead of saying,
a echo's really bothering me,
clicking his pen over there,
it's going to drive me crazy.
Can you maybe talk to him about his pen etiquette and have him stop that because
you're not doing it today.
But there was a,
there was an episode where he had the pen in his hand.
Things got a little bit fidgety and,
uh,
I didn't let it bother me.
You know what I did?
Yeah.
Brought them a new pen that didn't have the clicker on it.
That's a partnership for that situation.
You know,
in today's world,
we have so many people that are so offended by certain things and,
and it's,
it's the same principle there is that if you offend me,
that's really more my problem than it is your problem.
You know,
it's,
uh,
I'm the one that decides if you offend me.
So,
so I need to change my idea of what's offensive.
Uh,
one of the things that,
and,
and you know,
we're,
it's easy to sit and laugh here a little bit about some of this stuff,
but one of your chapters is called insanity.
And,
um,
I'm going to the book here.
The first I knew of it was in the fall of 1968 and I didn't understand an old
beat up French ambulance ramp rattled into the courtyard and an American wearing
prison garb crawl bout.
He weaved like a robot with head down and shoulders slumped.
It was odd guards never allowed POW is to walk that way.
We devil timed.
Who was this man?
Had he just come from the hospital?
Was He tortured into semi consciousness or was he faking?
When would we find out the man was hallucinatory insisting that his cellmates
were communists piece together with limbs and heads of dead Americans.
Whose arm is that?
He asked,
is that my pilot's arm?
How can you call me,
speak such good English?
Because this man was wasting away,
was necessary for his cellmates to force feed him.
The hostile patient was still strong,
requiring four or five men to constrain him so that a bamboo stick could be
forced between his teeth.
Another prisoner mashed rice down his throat.
When they finished,
he would gag himself to regurgitate what he thought was poisoned from the
Communists,
spewing rice all over the room.
He was in trance.
When the Vietnamese entered the room,
he refused to bow,
angered a guard,
scream,
Bao,
and whipped his fist across the expressionless face.
The man continued to stand.
The guards continued to beat him.
UNMERCIFULLY
and you guys can send you to see this.
Every six months or so,
we saw our sick pow comrade transported between solitary confinement and the
hospital.
We felt helpless.
The only way we could assist was with prayer after September,
1970.
We never saw him again.
There's a little more to that story that I did not know when I wrote the book
that he had been a part of a,
of an experiment.
Then by a Cuban,
uh,
the Cuban came over to the communist country.
And as near as we could tell,
his sole purpose of being in Vietnam was to establish the breaking point of an
American fighting man.
And so this guy that I'm talking about in the book,
and I didn't,
didn't know his name at the time,
I wrote the book,
Earl Cobell was actually tortured to insanity.
Uh,
and that's,
and that is why he was insane.
And,
uh,
and so his roommates then,
he was very belligerent and eh,
I mean,
here's another leadership principle cause you've got a group of guys in that
prison cell that were being threatened and some of them were,
were,
had broken bones or lacerations because of this crazy man.
He goes on a hunger strike in,
it's going to kill himself by not eating.
And they had to decide whether or not they were going to force feed him and keep
him alive and bring him back to his belligerence or let him die.
And so it was,
it was quite a dilemma in the prison camp and quite a dramatic time,
uh,
when that was happening.
And,
and they did,
they force feed him and brought him back to health.
And then,
uh,
the Vietnamese for reasonable,
we never really knew,
but possibly because they saw that we had some control and they didn't want us
to have that control.
They pulled him out of that cell,
put him in solitary confinement and,
and then he died,
uh,
after that.
But uh,
but it was a,
it was a tragic event,
uh,
that a guy would be tortured to the point of insanity.
And that was the purpose of the torture.
Thinks it exactly there you said,
you said they were the purpose and on purpose.
It's perfectly [inaudible] sticking point.
Yeah.
To find the breaking point.
And they found it with this,
with coble
you have another chapter,
and we touched on this a little bit earlier about faith.
Going back to the book of I will be dumb.
That will be done.
It seem presumptuous to try to change God's will to make a deal with the
omnipotent.
If I promise to devote my life to the ministry extreme in exchange for freedom
and failed to follow through what then?
No.
Trying to bargain with God was unfitting from the beginning.
I offered prayers of acceptance.
I remembered the experience of seeing the Christ light shadow in the Green Nabil
Room and the comfort I felt in that time of great need.
That day I asked God for strength under whatever hardship I might face and I
prayed for an not for her fidelity or success,
but for tolerance,
courage,
and most of all her happiness with or without me.
I continued to this daily prayer.
Now this was faith was not just yours but everyone in.
Here we go again showing some of the power that you guys had as prisoners.
Back to the book.
Thousands of bibles had been sent to us from church groups all over the world,
but the Vietnamese gave us none.
Asking wasn't enough,
so we decided to go on a hunger strike.
Our senior officer informed the Vietnamese that we simply didn't want more food
until we could have a bible,
an uninterrupted worship.
They retaliated by shutting off our drinking water.
After a few days,
the Vietnamese were ready to settle and so were we.
They would give us a church service.
If we abided by certain stipulations,
the service would be held according to their schedule.
No one could sing,
no one could stand and everyone to here strictly to camp regulations.
Every word spoken in the ceremony was to be written down for the sensors
perusal.
After all the restrictions,
we hadn't gained much,
but at least the V had given an inch.
After a few weeks later,
the V saw that our services,
we're not militant and relaxed restrictions.
They permitted a Forman choir to sing to hymns.
Most important.
They gave us a Bible for two days.
Yeah.
So you guys decided to hold the line on that one?
We did.
And um,
and it wasn't easy.
They,
an interesting thing back to the leadership was the,
the guy who promoted this was a very staunch Christian Guy.
The number two in command was an atheist.
And,
and,
and really had no great interest in having the Bible in the cell.
And so when the number one guy,
um,
told the Vietnamese that we were going to go on a hunger strike,
they hauled them out of there,
that they took him away so that the number two guy,
the atheist was suddenly in charge.
And it was interesting to watch what was going to happen here.
And it was very encouraging when the atheist said,
continue the hunger strike,
we're going to get this Bible.
That's awesome.
You talk about
their perception of the Vietnamese perception of,
of religion in general.
Back to the book of the large majority of Vietnamese were not Catholic.
However,
and when they discovered us in prayer as they did only the last year,
they asked what,
what you derive from this thing?
God.
We tried to explain that we received strength,
comfort,
help,
and promise of eternal life.
These concepts were too difficult for them,
yet many seemed interested and did not mock our beliefs to the diehard
Vietnamese communist.
The state was their God,
their truth,
their way.
They're light,
the controlling body and the government decreed infallible cannons without fear
of correction.
Whenever peasants asked who is the state,
they were told that they themselves were and that they had control and making
decisions.
Each was told that he was part of the [inaudible] state.
He was,
as long as he didn't interfere,
I consider my confinement in prison to be spiritually beneficial.
I was given an opportunity that few men have the time to pause,
to reflect and to establish priorities.
I found that my previous value system was unrealistic,
stripped of all my material wealth,
the only beacon I could home home in on was my faith.
It an unchanging God.
Okay,
and you also went very deep on thoughts around patriotism
and here's your toss.
Talking about patriotism.
Some pdws were super patriots feeling.
The United States could do no wrong.
A few felt that we had made a mistake and then it was time for us to get out
with most of the prisoners.
I accepted the fact that we were not perfect,
but felt that we were fighting for a worthy cause and should persevere until the
end.
And this is something I brought up on many occasions.
The fact of how hard we were.
No,
I fought in the war in Iraq and we went through extreme measures to try and
protect the civilian populace and the civilian infrastructure.
And here's your comments on that.
Back to the book,
great efforts were made to persevere the lives and property of civilians.
Pilots were threatened with court martial if they failed to pinpoint accurate
military targets,
even to the extent that they would jeopardize their own lives by swooping just
above tree tops to preserve a peasant hut 50 yards from a Sam radar scope.
The Vietnamese capitalizing on this may targets especially difficult by placing
their military equipment in the middle of peasant hamlets or next to schools.
In fact,
several antiaircraft artillery guns were stationed on hospital rooftops
and your,
your thoughts about the involvement here,
the most powerful free nation in history could not idly watch the communist
world gobble up and dissolve sovereign nations.
We had to play the surgeon to excise the malignant disease of mind control.
I don't condone war.
I think there are few justifiable reasons for killing.
In Vietnam.
War was a last ditch effort of international diplomacy.
It was difficult to justify my six years of imprisonment when politicians with
expense paid trips to Paris should have solved the problems through negotiation.
In this case,
our negotiations,
we're at the end of their rope.
The communist didn't understand anything but the big hammer when our be 50 twos
shattered her noise defenses with thousands of bombs.
The Vietnamese realized we meant business
and this thought here we faced east once a week and pledge our allegiance.
We contracted our bill of rights and the Constitution to the communist manifesto
daily.
We saw how big brother destroyed individuality.
Yeah.
We compared our lot with that of the guards while prisoners of war were behind
bars,
the Vietnamese war captives inside their own bamboo borders.
Yeah.
We consider ourselves more fortunate than day.
Okay.
One day we would leave our cells.
Powerful statement and that's exactly the way we thought was that that they were
the prisoners and we weren't.
We were always,
we were always
of the belief that we would go home and they had to stay there.
You know,
they,
they had to stay in their prison and we would eventually be released.
And you were right.
And during the week of 21 to 28,
January,
1973 for the first time,
treatment was actually humane.
The Vietnamese set up a volleyball net and allowed us to play or to exercise.
They gave us books and magazines from home.
We knew something was happening.
So you guys started to sense that
there was,
and you,
and you talk about this in the book.
I didn't go into it much,
but there was always some people that were,
uh,
what'd you call it?
The people that would look at the amount of food you got?
Oh yes,
they would,
they would read the amount of rice you'd be given as to some foreseeing the
future of how long you're going to be in there for what you call him in the
book.
Uh,
we call them,
um,
I forgot
like food at Terry and
no gas drawn numbers.
Yes.
Astronomers,
astronomers,
anyone.
That's all they gave us more rice.
We must be getting ready to be released.
And you have that
feeling,
it sounds like,
you know,
once a year,
once,
once every 18 months out.
Oh yeah.
Well of course it depended on the person,
but some of the guys were so optimistic and uh,
and I was an optimist,
you know,
I've,
I would think a,
you know,
home,
in fact,
when I was first shot down,
uh,
I,
I thought we had finally given him the big blow.
You know,
we finally brought them to their knees on the 19th of May and,
and the first few days in prison or that,
you know,
this is really going to be our Ronnie because of the war is over and I fly home
and,
and my squadron has to take the ship home.
I will be there to greet them when they come home.
It doesn't matter.
He is the positive attitude that is optimistic.
Those poor guys have to ride the ship back.
I'm going to be home before then.
Oh Man.
That's like I was,
I've said this
one of the podcast.
I always,
when I'm in an in a commercial aircraft flying,
I always think if this thing blows up in the sky,
I'm going to live.
I'm going to be that guy for you know,
of course I'm not going to kick it.
Sure.
Everyone else is going to die,
not me.
Uh,
and so finally,
here we go.
Back to the book,
the Camp Commander,
once a game called our group together about 180 of us old timers.
He was the first time that all prisoners in the camp were gathered in one place.
We lined up by buildings in military formation and we're called to attention by
our acting wing commander,
lieutenant colonel,
norm Gattis.
Although Vietnamese officials did not recognize our rank structure,
they said nothing.
The camp commander read an announcement and the interpreter read the
translation.
It had been a long time since I'd heard English words.
So professionally when he finished and told us we could go,
our wing commander again called us to attention and dismissed us with bowed
heads.
With heads bowed,
we walked quietly back to our rooms.
We were stunned.
Some had waited for these words for over eight and one half years of the war was
over.
We were going home.
Okay.
Did that even feel real at that point?
You have to get your hopes up.
So many times it really didn't.
And they tried to trick us many times.
You know,
they would call us in,
Hey,
sign this confession,
we'll send you home.
And uh,
and so even when it happened for real,
it,
we couldn't believe it.
It wasn't really until we find that I've got a board that,
uh,
that see one 41 and it took off the wheels in the well,
and when there was a little,
uh,
a little bit of a administrative situation when it came time,
cause you guys had all new that you're gonna follow the order that you are
capitol of the sick and injured.
We're going to go first,
then the enlisted guys,
we're going to go and then order of capture.
Exactly.
And that was part of the plums.
Right.
Okay.
That,
that was,
that was part of all of the rules that had,
that,
that we've were abiding by.
And so we were in,
we were numbered,
okay.
Sick and ancient guys got a went whoa.
And then it was our turn,
but by number of the date of Sudan and they pulled 20 of us out that were out of
order of the shoot down date.
And,
uh,
we made a big deal of this and a that.
And they,
they told us,
well,
Kissinger told us that we,
we almost caused an international incident because for whatever reason that we
really never knew for sure,
except that all 20 of us had,
um,
had some,
some disappointing,
um,
uh,
feature to our return.
And we never knew if that was the reason or not,
but we review either coming back to deaths in the family or disease or divorce
or that kind of thing.
All 20 guys.
And so,
but we were out of order and we did not know why we were out of order.
And so we,
we told them we weren't going home and he went back and forth for almost a day,
uh,
that we really
to go home and then find the,
uh,
Colonel Gaddis just pulled you in and said,
listen,
you guys are going home.
He gave us the direct order.
Okay.
And then you get to the airport at the airport,
the bus halted near pockmark runways.
We exited solidly through a crowd of people and by microphone we were told to
walk to our receiving officer when our names were called.
As I heard my name,
I stepped past a table where Vietnamese and American representatives marked off
the exchange.
I saluted the colonel than another and was escorted by an officer who was so
excited he could have,
he could say nothing more than,
isn't it great?
It's so nice to have you back.
We've all been waiting for you.
Isn't it great?
I felt as though he had previously composed what he would say,
but in his excitement,
his record stuck.
He was right.
That was great.
I walked up on the ramp of the [inaudible] 41 and saw the first navy uniform.
The officer inside that uniform grabbed me and hugged me and told me his name.
I didn't know him until he told me he was the briefing officer on the Kitty
Hawk.
The day I was shot down,
Gary Mauro and I had once worked many hours together and now we can joyfully
recall old times.
As soon as I was in the airplane and nurse kissed me and started the first of a
long chain of flash bulbs,
we were given American cigarettes magazines than information sheets telling us
what to expect at Clark Air Force Base.
The pilot taxi down the runway pushed off,
pushed the throttles and at the moment of liftoff,
suddenly it hit us.
We were off north Vietnamese soil.
We screamed above the noise of the engines minutes later,
who you're soaring above the Gulf of Tonkin and saw some of our ships.
The commander of the Seventh Fleet sent a message of welcome and Jim returned to
the radio comm with a thankful acknowledgement by nightfall.
We reached the Philippines and Clark Air Force Base.
As soon as the doors opened,
we could see and hear the enthusiasm from what must have been 5,000 people,
banners and bans,
choral groups and cheerleaders.
Everyone seemed to be there.
I walked down the ramp,
saluted a general and then an outro.
As I shook the admiral's hand,
I was so overcome with emotion
that I hugged him.
So you hugged the admiral?
That was embarrassing.
I don't know why I did that.
Uh,
you know,
it was just maybe take a stab.
I would augment.
Kissed him.
Who'd been on.
Thank you sir.
Yes sir.
You're allowed to hug the animal when you come home after that.
No,
that's good.
I could tell what you wrote that you were sort of like what I just do exactly
overcome with emotions and then you start kind of the in processing thing and
I'm that I had to be,
when they started handing you magazines,
it's cigarettes and food and all that and you go into that somewhat in here
where they're just,
how overwhelming is that?
That was wonderful.
It was joyful.
You know,
I was reading through some Vietnam pow poetry and I got caught,
you know,
I was just looking for background.
I want to learn more and you know,
people express themselves and poetry and I've got locked into probably a dozen
poems that was nothing but different foods like raspberry cake and I just steak
in milk and chocolate milk in every fee.
It was like a thousand pounds.
It would just about food.
So my,
my favorite one was Jerry coffee wrote a poem.
It was called Ode to a weevil and the poem was little weeble in my bread.
I think I just bit off your head.
That was it.
That was the end of the,
it was the end of the weevil too.
That's kind of dope.
So you guys,
you guys are,
you know,
uh,
that had to be somewhat overwhelming,
but you know,
like you said,
you guys,
uh,
you guys were,
were in good,
relatively good mental status.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Now as you're going through the motions with the doctors and the physical people
in the,
uh,
the,
the PA's,
the public affairs people,
okay.
You're saying,
hey,
you know what,
why don't I see my wife,
what's up with my wife?
And no one's really answering that question for you and find that you get the
chaplain and you say,
going back to the book here,
I looked up at him and said,
chaplain,
I have a great deal of faith in you and I want you to level with me.
So far I haven't been able to get a straight answer from anyone and I want to
know about my wife.
Would you please be kind enough to tell me what's going on?
And he says back,
well Charlie,
there is a problem with your wife.
She as well.
But she has some misgivings.
I'm not sure as to the extent,
but I'm sure that everything is going to be all right.
She's written me a letter but I didn't want to open it.
I felt that you should
and you get the letter and it's nothing crystal clear,
but the message is clear enough that you know she's not want to stay married to
you anymore.
And you call her
the next day.
Actually he called my,
my parents first.
Okay.
Back in Kansas.
Uh,
I tried to call her,
but,
uh,
it didn't,
it didn't work.
In fact,
they were,
they were very protective,
you know,
first of all,
they thought they thought I might be suicidal when I heard the news.
And so they were very protective of me and I,
uh,
they wouldn't,
they wouldn't let me call home.
Um,
even the chaplain in the psychiatrist and psychologist wouldn't lend called home
even to your parents?
Even to my parents.
Yeah.
They had this plan of how they were going to explain this to me,
I guess,
but they wouldn't let me call.
I finally found a social worker in the hospital,
you know,
hey,
I want to,
don't want to,
you got to telephone around here.
So I found a phone and I call my parents back in Kansas and,
um,
and they're the ones that actually told me,
I'll never forget my mom's words.
She said,
it sounded give 10 years of my life if it didn't have to tell you this,
but she's engaged to be married to another man.
She's,
she's filed for divorce.
And judge wouldn't give her a divorce.
You know,
the,
the um,
the justification was a abandonment,
you know,
and she said her husband had had been abandoned her and the judge wasn't buying
that and so,
but no,
that was the first day I knew was when my mother told me that she had filed for
divorce.
Um,
going back to the book here a few days later.
So he talked to Ann.
But then some of the stuff you say here is I actually,
I just,
I just have to quote it back the book yet,
and had told me that she wanted to remarry,
I would not become an obstacle to her happiness.
I called her parents and they seemed quite unsettled about Ann's decision.
A few days later I called Dan again and she complained that many members in the
news media had been harassing her.
She said she had often been misquoted and was the victim of character
assassination.
I then talked personally to some of the newspaper men and told them that I did
not want her to be more aligned in any way.
In fact,
I wanted them to say nothing at all about my wife.
For the most part.
They were receptive to my wishes.
I gave them a quote,
which they could use if they felt they had to.
The divorces regrettable is a real credible but inevitable drifting apart.
After so many years.
By this time,
my hope for reconciliation was dead.
I was determined to take it on the chin and roll with the punches.
Well,
I may be coming off as a white knight here,
but it wasn't at all that way.
She,
I really to this day believe that in many ways the ladies had it worse than we
did.
You know,
and it's the,
it's the families back here.
You know what I mean?
The military guys are over there and I'm sure you've seen this in,
in your experience as well,
is that we,
we believe in what we're doing.
We're dedicated,
we focused,
you know,
we're over there having a high old time.
The families back here don't have that.
And especially my wife didn't know if I was alive or dead from one day to the
next.
She went through the same years,
24 to 30 than I did.
She was supposed to be faithful to me and she was supposed to,
you know,
believe that I'd coming home,
not knowing if I'd ever come home and if I did,
would I still want to be married or would I be a basket case and a burden to
her,
the rest of her life.
And the other part of this,
which was,
which I didn't know at the time,
of course,
but she lost her support group.
You know,
they had a big wives club,
that's the squadron pilots.
All of our wives got together and they would take pictures and send us cookies
and make tapes and all these things.
And it was a very close knit group.
The,
the,
the wives of the pilots,
well,
when I was shot down or when anybody was killed or captured,
that wife was sort of summarily shunned by the rest of the group.
Not Officially,
but just because they didn't,
they didn't want to,
um,
they didn't know what to say and they didn't want to be associated with somebody
who had that problem.
They didn't want,
they didn't want that to affect their life.
So she lost her support group.
She,
uh,
she went back to Kansas and went back to school there.
And then when she fell in love with this other guy,
she lost what support group.
She had it at home because her parents were upset.
My parents were upset.
I have a brother 10 years younger than I am,
that that looks a lot like me.
And he was of the,
about the same age during this,
the letter part of this experience that I had been when,
when in and I met and he would go over to mow her lawn in Kansas and she would
break out in hives,
serious emergency room kind of hives,
uh,
just at the site of my little brother because he looked like me.
And,
and so they finally,
uh,
the doctors restricted him from ever seen her because it caused her so much
grief.
So it was tough on the ladies.
Anyway,
you look at it and I saw that and I felt that and I felt like I needed to do
whatever was necessary to give her a little piece.
Well,
you might not say thank you,
came off like a white knight,
but that's a pretty awesome treatment of someone for sure.
Well,
and a lot of people,
um,
you know,
didn't understand it then and,
and even don't understand it to today.
And you know,
some people want to blame her,
but by I have no animosity,
no blame whatsoever.
Um,
for what she did.
I mean,
it was,
uh,
I have other people that will say,
well,
don't you wish that she had known early on that she was going to divorce you?
No Way.
I would say no to her.
No.
Her,
her,
the thoughts of her kept me alive.
You know,
that was,
that was my purpose was to go back and be with her.
The fact that it didn't happen.
Of course there's somewhat incidental,
but the six years I was there,
it was certainly a positive for me to think about her.
And,
uh,
you wrap up the book with a chapter called Reflections,
which is just phenomenal and you know,
looking back it kind of what you learned there.
I'm going to hit some of the sum of the parts of it because there's so much that
everybody can,
can learn from this.
Going here to the book are closed.
Society subsisted we ate,
slept,
breathed.
We laughed and we cried.
We were frustrated and we were gratified.
We were embarrassed and we were proud.
Slowly,
almost imperceptibly particular patterns of behavior edged into our daily
activities and came until they became folk folkways.
There was nothing unusual about a man pacing the floor for hours like a caged
tiger.
No one,
no notice was given to the man lifting a soup bowl and licking it's spotless.
There was no stigma in baring our souls to one another.
We had our own Moore's and sense of propriety.
Our micro chasm was a petri dish containing its own strains and culture.
Although we had not been handpicked,
we were for the most part out of the same mold that of the professional officer
and pilot.
We were unique prisoners who acted differently
from those of Korea or World War II.
We had been exposed to a different selection process and a new era of lifestyles
gathered together in a dubious fraternity of Hanoi's skydivers.
We were a group of cocky individuals.
We knew we were the best,
okay.
Stripped of personal possessions of million dollar airplanes of rank and
prestige.
We suddenly found ourselves at the bottom of a dark pit.
We could no longer look outward.
Our only alternative was to make the best of what we had.
And when you have so little and for you guys to take that attitude,
then there's so many people,
you know,
when I hear from people all over the world,
that will reach out to me and talk about the situation that they're in a bad
situation,
in a negative situation and,
and you know,
it's hearing from people like you that makes everyone realize I need to make the
best of what I have.
You know,
I need to make the best of the situation I'm in.
Because if you guys could do it,
anyone can.
Again,
if this sounds like grand,
high level philosophy,
but it was,
it was almost a survival technique.
You know,
it's almost,
hey,
this is the way that we can make it through.
This is a,
is believing in,
in the future and believing in ourselves.
And I look back on that six years and it was probably the most important six
years of my life because,
because I came through this silly experience with,
um,
with this kind of,
this kind of discipline,
it is kind of thought process that,
hey,
uh,
it's not the hand you're dealt.
It's the way you play the hand you're dealt.
And you may not have four aces this,
this around.
You know,
you may have trash,
but if you play it right,
it can still be a winning hand.
A little bit of talk about you coming home.
Back to the book of my first impressions of home,
we're not too encouraging.
Newspapers and magazines were devoted largely to the drug problem.
Permissiveness,
the energy crisis,
a bounding crime rate and eroding and eroding and eroding family structures.
I was worried,
worried from a selfish viewpoint.
I had sacrificed many years from my country and I didn't want some young
whippersnappers destroying it,
but I decided to give myself a one year moratorium before taking a firm stand on
any of my observations.
Okay?
And I've found that the news media in particular had exaggerated the negative.
I didn't have my wallet stolen,
stolen,
nor did I see opium dens or gang wars when I visited schools instead.
I was pleasantly surprised with student demeanor.
Young people freely ask questions and showed a genuine concern for answers to
me.
They seem to have been unduly criticized by an inpatient adult society rather
than given,
been given wise counsel.
They have more freedom and I think they are generally capable of handling those
freedoms.
They're more mature than their counterparts of my generation.
They have to be to survive.
And one of the reasons I called that little section out is because guess what we
hear about the millennials right now.
We hear the same thing about the millennials and maybe just everyone should give
a little moratorium on themselves.
I'm going to start imposing more and more.
It's Williams all myself.
I think that's a great idea.
Whoever started definitely doing that self imposed moratorium.
Yeah.
You see you here and meet with us.
You know,
we work with a lot of businesses and companies and people will ask us about you.
We got these millennials and and it's so hard to lead them.
And I say,
Oh,
why is that?
Because they want to understand why they're doing what they're doing because
they want to know what the goal and purpose of their of of their job is that
that's nothing new.
Oh.
Because there,
because they want to step up and run things.
I want that person working for me,
so
yeah,
put a little more him right
back to the book.
While in prison,
I had a lot of time to think.
The same question kept popping in my mind.
What am I doing here?
I'm 10,000 miles from home cooped up in a communist prison camp on able to enjoy
all the wonderful freedoms I was sent here to protect.
My first answer was obvious.
I'm fighting for my country.
I'm serving the United States of America.
I'd learned in school that America was Purple Mountain Majesties and amber,
amber waves of grain,
that it was congress and the executive and the judiciary.
These were self evident,
but I had to get more personal than that.
America had demean more.
It had to relate to my own freedoms,
the product of nearly 200 years of a pioneering spirit.
My nation is a skinny kid who climbs on his bike before dawn to sling
newspapers.
My country is a librarian who sits behind glasses with pencil in are here and as
quick to find answers to my questions.
My homeland is a truck driver who smiles down from his cab and signals me
through the intersection.
My America is a personal friend and I am proud to serve her
and you and you go on to say that there must be a thousand definitions for
freedom.
Mine is simple.
Freedom is the ability to walk through the door.
It's not the act of walking through.
That's proof of freedom.
It's not going to church or speaking one's mind or demonstrating in the streets.
Freedom is the ability to choose whether to go to church.
To step up on a soap box to carry placards.
Now that I am released again,
I move about it.
Will I say what I wish I criticize and take criticism?
I feel freer now than ever before because I know what freedom is.
I appreciate those freedoms because I was once denied them.
And is there anything,
is there anybody that appreciates freedoms more than people that have had those
freedoms denied?
Probably not.
Is there any way to transfer the appreciation for those freedoms?
I mean,
I'm sure
doing my darnedest to you and your darkness and uh,
you were in the same business.
You know,
I,
I speak a couple of times a week all over the country have stuff.
So I came home trying to impress this on people.
But the truth is there's no way that you or I can't put people in that situation
that we've been in and make them feel the way they feel.
There's no way I could deny a person a freedom.
I do corporate workshops,
uh,
as you do.
And,
uh,
and I'll put,
I'll put a person in her in a room by themselves with nothing there for 15
minutes and they go crazy.
You know?
Do you take their phone away from them?
Yeah.
You can cut that down to five.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They're going nice.
And so,
uh,
there's very little,
well I should say it this way,
it's difficult to make that transfer to make a person to appreciate freedom when
they've never lost theirs.
And all I can do is tell them
the story.
Yeah.
And I appreciate your helping me tell the story I'm trying over here.
I'm going to,
you know,
occasionally I just have to go that a little bit of the distance on some stuff
that have to read in here.
This is one of those situations to,
to wrap up because I think this is just a such an important message for me.
For everybody.
Back to the book,
I'm often asked,
how did you do it,
commander?
How could you take six years of filth,
brutality and loneliness?
I could have never done it.
Okay.
My answer is,
of course you could.
As a matter of fact that you rub elbows each day with people who have done it.
We weren't the only prisoners.
Millions of Americans have experienced the manacles of the body or shackles of
the mind.
They have been bound by unfortunate external circumstances,
automobile accidents,
disease,
natural disaster,
paralyzing grief from the loss of a loved one.
They've suffered deprivation and humiliation
once a victim of misfortune,
many become too insecure to open doors.
Instead,
they allow themselves to wallow in despair.
They become alcoholics.
Drug addicts on faithful wives or husbands,
unruly children
in ability to face personal responsibility is often hidden and seemingly
innocent.
Pastimes,
golf,
poker,
television,
sleep.
Yeah.
These diversions spawn intense feeling of guilt and worthlessness
and some victims ultimately isolate themselves and become despondent.
Okay.
A few commit suicide.
I had ample opportunity to damn society and curse my fate.
Okay,
but what good would that have done
to be sure that Vietnamese would not have released me simply because I felt
sorry for myself.
Yeah.
On the contrary,
they used to every available means to make that happen.
A despondent prisoner was a prime candidate for communist indoctrination.
My secret for enduring six years of hell is really not a secret at all.
First and foremost,
if I had faith in God knowing that his will would be done,
I never doubted that I could persevere.
I simply trusted God's promise to answer my prayers.
I also loved my country,
its people,
and its freedoms.
I realized that because of the human element,
mistakes could be made,
but in growing up,
I had discerned that most of the people in this great land or on a very
honorable and compassionate
second,
I had self-discipline.
It would have been easier to avoid church torture by succumbing to north
Vietnamese interrogation.
It would've been easier to assume helplessness.
By blaming an evil world,
I could have rationalized myself into mental and physical paralysis.
However,
strict self obedience gave me the ability to persevere.
Finally,
I had pride.
I was proud to know and omnipotent God.
I was proud of my country and its heritage.
I was proud of my family.
I was proud of myself.
Faith,
disciplined,
pride.
Each of these nurture the others combined.
They allowed me to endure.
I have joined the ranks of millions of Americans who've applied heroic
principles in overcoming hardships.
Okay?
Every day a disabled veteran steps away from his wheelchair everyday.
Uh,
life is resumed after a death in the family.
Friendships erase,
loneliness.
Addicts throwaway the crutch of alcohol or drugs or obsessions.
Every day someone discovers how to love life,
no matter what the obstacle,
every day someone sees the light at the end of the tunnel,
these ordinary Americans are not held in esteem as heroes,
yet they have suffered grave misfortune and have recovered just as I.
So you see,
I'm no hero.
And I think it's that very humility,
sir,
that makes you a hero because you are certainly a hero to me and certainly a
hero to this great nation.
Well,
thank you.
Thank you for that.
And I am so those bouquets right back at you.
You're one of my heroes.
I don't accept sir.
Not at all.
Um,
you know,
as you look at other people's struggle
with all the things that you mentioned,
the drugs,
the alcohol,
the obsession,
depression after the loss of a loved one,
how can people find the faith,
the discipline and the pride that you talk about?
What do you think is that colonel,
that starting point that allows those things to grow in someone's mind so that
they can overcome these kinds of challenge?
I think the first seed that you have to plant in nurture in your mind is that
you still have the choice that you still are in control.
Because I think so many people that get bogged down with these challenges we're
talking about assume that there's no way out that,
that it's somebody else's problem or somebody else has to affect their lives and
they feel like they have no control over the,
over the outcome.
And so I think that's the beginning part of it is that,
um,
each of us makes decisions every day that control our destiny.
And it truly is not the things around us.
It's,
it's our,
our approach to the things around us.
It's our definition of the things around us.
It's our willingness to accept a challenge and make choices about the things
around us.
And so if he can,
if you can nurture that,
if you can believe that,
yes,
I have control of my life,
I am,
I am the master of my fate.
I'm the captain of my soul.
Um,
and if you can really believe that,
then the rest is just a matter of the discipline it takes to work through it.
You know,
it's an interesting,
I was talking to,
you know,
I was talking to your son Alex,
and we were talking about how,
you know,
as he was growing up and he was hearing your sort of philosophy of life and the
world,
and,
and when he heard me on,
on a podcast and he started saying,
wait a second,
I've heard,
I've heard this kind of stuff.
And,
and,
and we were talking about how,
you know,
I've,
I've Kinda said that now that you know,
there's some,
I hate to go so far as to say universal truths,
but there's certainly some things in human nature and human life that are very
similar across the board.
And when you take people and you put them through this,
this,
this crazy thing of life and you provide them with some similar challenges,
they're going to come to very similar conclusions.
And,
and from what you just said,
you know,
there's two things that you said that I say all the time and number one,
this perspective of,
you know,
what's that initial spark to say,
Hey,
I can take discipline,
I can take pride.
The first thing in my mind you've got to say is like,
okay,
these problems that are happening,
I can,
I got to take ownership of what I can do.
I'm going to take ownership on my problems.
I can't blame this guy.
Can't play Mac guy.
I got to take ownership too of them.
And that's the first thing.
And then the other piece that you said that I say all the time is you've got
decisions to make.
You've got little decisions to make,
and if you can make that right decision,
if you can do the right thing at that moment in time,
it's not going to change your life.
That one decision won't change your life.
But then you're going to three minutes later,
30 seconds later,
an hour later,
kind of make another decision.
And can you hold the line and get yourself pointed in the right direction and
can you have the discipline to do that?
Can you have the faith in yourself that you're going to make that happen?
And can you have the pride?
And you know a Dick Winters talked about that too on Los Po last podcast.
You know,
Dick winters from the first of five or six band of brothers.
But one of the big things that he was concerned about with his men was if the,
if he still saw them begin to lose pride and how a,
if I don't care what echo thanks to me,
if I come in here,
I'm not ready for this podcast,
and he's going to look at me like,
oh,
I guess chocolate was just letting it slide and all of a sudden if I don't care
anymore,
I don't care anymore.
Now I'm not preparing.
Now I'm not getting ready.
And then you take someone in combat and they start to lose pride and all of a
sudden they say,
I don't care who sees me acting
the wrong way.
Who sees me slacking off on a watch,
who sees me not cleaning my weapon if I don't care about that anymore.
That's the beginning of that downward spiral.
And Pride is one of those
things that you have to be careful of because just like any other dichotomy that
we have as human beings,
yes,
you can get so much pride that you no longer think you can do anything wrong,
which we know where that leads.
That's right.
And you can have not enough pride to keep yourself on the right path.
Great.
Amazing stuff.
Uh,
yeah.
Echo.
Did you have any questions?
Just wondering.
Well,
this is one part I kind of want it to reflect on that I thought was pretty
important.
Even on a smaller,
he liked the part where you were regarding the,
um,
the guards as in their own prison,
you know,
so you almost like he said that they had it worse than you did.
So this one time my wife told me this story where she was in the checkout line
in the store.
A lot of stuff happens in the checkout line.
A lot of things happen when the grocery store with lot of lessons,
a lot of lessons.
So she was,
she found herself in the express line,
but she had more than the 15 items.
And the guy behind her started,
he was tripping the whole time though.
So she's paying,
she's trying to hurry up and he's like,
you,
you know,
what do you call loud talking like talking to the person next to him about my
life.
So after the whole ordeal,
it was kind of like a scene,
you know.
So my wife afterwards just like,
oh I hope you have a nice day.
You know,
like I,
you know,
she left.
Did she say it earnestly?
Yeah,
that didn't sound real earnest and I don't think that she probably,
yeah,
she was probably self d for sure.
But at the end of the day,
it's kind of like a,
I hope you have a nice day and shit.
So she told me that story and she was like,
but you know what a big part of me was like,
he has to go home with himself,
you know,
and I get to come home and be cool and have all my girl,
all this stuff.
I was like,
Dang,
that's a good way to look at it.
Cause he has to go home.
He's probably pissed.
Yeah.
For the day.
And you know,
she gets to go home with 17 grocery items to
reason through the checkout line.
It's true.
Um,
oh yeah.
One question.
You know,
when you got arrested,
when you bought that scooter,
the Christian figured about this because I've been in this experience because
you get the scooter ray,
you pack your friend.
Yeah.
Right.
And then the top say stop you.
That happened to us all the time.
But why did they arrest you though is,
I mean,
is it like,
hey,
you guys can't do that.
You're going to jail.
Uh,
well I,
it was rather unusual I think for these,
these cops to see these two little guys.
You know,
we were 13 and 14 years old and then we weren't very big to begin with.
And then the motor scooter was bigger than we were and it's in the middle of the
night and were,
I think they,
they felt,
they felt like there was something suspicious.
Took it.
He's stolen.
Well,
uh,
all right.
Echo what sir?
Do you have anything else on that,
on that right there?
Nope.
Okay.
Uh,
no,
no further details on the scooter rides.
We got that clear.
We'll drop that echo.
Um,
you know,
do you think that you could maybe
tell us how to support the podcast?
Sure.
What to work.
Of course they can't.
That's what I'm here for.
One of the many reasons.
So,
um,
if you want to support this podcast many ways,
first way you can support yourself.
I,
I said it before,
I'm gonna say it again on it.
Supplements,
right?
You're doing physical stuff,
supplements that gets you through.
I'm not gonna spend too much time on it.
I want to,
I won't.
I'm going to recommend the Krill oil and the strong boom.
That's it.
See now just sir,
I'm not letting this annoy me.
I'm just going to go,
I'm just like,
okay with it.
It's my problem.
I don't want to listen to him talk.
That's my problem.
He has the right to speak for a long hours about this stuff.
Here's the thing.
They'll part,
like,
let's say you were to get annoyed.
The only reason you'd be annoyed they get annoyed is because you know this
stuff.
Some people they don't know.
There's all those people that maybe they want to hear it again on your every
word.
But the good thing about on it,
you know that's a good stuff cause supplements can be kind of junk sometimes,
but this is the 100% these,
this is the good stuff and their stuff for everything in life,
everything.
We only talk about the Krill oil,
some other stuff,
but you go on their protein wellness to even like digest it.
Everything they got on there on it.com that's where you get it.
If you want 10% off on it.com/jocko
another way before you do your Amazon shopping,
clickthrough Jocko,
podcast.com to do your Amazon shopping and then uh,
you know,
do your shopping is the,
is normal.
It's a good way to support small action.
Big reaction takes what,
three seconds?
Something like that.
Maybe for,
I don't know,
either way.
Do that.
That's a good way.
Also subscribed to the podcast if you haven't already.
That's iTunes,
stitcher,
Google play and other podcasting
platforms.
Subscribe on Youtube.
I put some excerpts on some more.
Last one.
That was a good one.
Good one,
12 minutes.
You're just so,
you know,
you're getting outside the boundaries of an excerpt.
Man.
I'm listening to it.
I'm like,
we don't want to our exercise right there,
but I'm like,
oh wait,
wait.
That kind of helped it,
you know?
Uh,
what was it?
It was a good one.
It's 12 minutes long.
Emotion.
Oh,
hangry.
Getting hangry.
Controlling.
You're stifling your emotions.
Emotions,
your emotions.
Yes,
exactly right.
When it's level two or lower on the Richter scale of emotions,
you can't behavior your emotions,
but your behavior can be based on anyway,
look at that little excerpt.
Uh,
put more on,
where do you search Jocko podcast.
Youtube.
Subscribe to that.
That's what you said,
director.
It's like a channel.
Youtube chicken.
It's like,
just like a,
it's a youtube channel.
Anyone who knows what youtube is.
Getting to know this.
I think I know a little,
but I didn't quite put all that together.
It's all good.
Bill.
I think you're already subscribed.
You get the notification.
You're all good.
100%.
Um,
also,
Jack was a store,
it's called Jocko store.
Jocko store.com.
There's some good stuff on their t shirts.
If you like t shirts,
we wear tee shirts,
right?
I know.
I do some women's stuff on their shirts.
Patches,
rash guards,
hoodies,
new rash guard out maybe.
Maybe,
maybe not.
You got to look Jocko stored out.
Come get some good stuff.
We got some kids stuff to him there.
Yeah,
that's right.
You're,
you're wearing one of those more.
Your kids does stuff if you're on youtube bug or hitting me up for warrior kid
tee shirts and,
and then immediately people said we want them for adults too.
So we made some for kids but then adults said we want them.
So now we've got warrior kids cause can you be a 45 year old warrior kid?
I think I am.
Yes sir.
I'm in the game as a warrior kid.
Yeah.
And if you didn't,
I mean you're going to obviously talk about the work where the word could book,
but man,
when you read that book you're like Dang,
I wish I would have read this.
Whether it be when I'm a kid,
I wish I would've read it one day before her.
Read it that day.
It's like that's how much you wish you would've known all this stuff.
Cause it's real basic,
but it's so deep,
man.
I'll go.
Jake's got some info.
Layers,
man.
Layers upon layers.
There's people now identifying layers on Twitter by the way,
which is a pre,
there's been some really good identification of layers.
There's some layers in that book.
Yeah,
they're going to get deeper too.
That's good.
So yeah,
you know.
Yeah.
Back to the store.
[inaudible] dot com you can see what's on there.
This is cool stuff and if you want to support,
get something,
you know,
also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
which I know you already do,
but in a small event that you don't,
it is an album on iTunes with tracks and Amazon music with tracks,
not music tracks,
spoken word checks.
Technically it's what's called spoken word number one,
by the way.
Yeah,
still still number one days that,
I mean for good reason because look,
he can put together a psychological warfare too,
and I've got some really good suggestions from everyone on things that need,
where we need help as a group.
So if you've got those hit hit us up on Twitter to give suggestions for
psychological warfare.
Two tracks.
Yeah.
What you need areas where we need help.
We all need help.
Yeah.
I got some,
some,
some uh,
request me 47 requests.
Yeah,
they're all my personal ones.
I think I got 48 now.
But yeah,
if you didn't know what that is,
it's like,
it's an album.
You get it.
You have a,
you know,
in your journey of what getting after it in,
you're getting after it journey,
but you're not strong the whole time.
You're just not,
yeah moments.
And most of us aren't.
You're going gonna have moments of weakness.
But guess what?
In those moments of weakness,
you listened to the designated track.
If you're having a weak moment of weakness when you're trying to wake up at four
30,
come on,
Bro.
That's,
that's early four 30.
Every day.
Yeah.
The day is probably going to come where you're like,
you know what,
I'm gonna hit this news.
Guess what?
Listen to get up and get affricate up and get after it.
There's like two or three of those two and I guarantee you won't hit the snooze.
You'll get up,
you'll get after it.
Anyway,
that's,
that's what I think with 100% certainty.
Anyway.
Again,
it's called psychological warfare.
It's on iTunes and Amazon music and some other places where you buy into some of
the music.
They're all,
all,
all a button in there.
Yeah.
Good.
And also by the way,
the book that we reviewed today with Captain Plumb,
it's available on Charlie plumb.com c h a r l I e P L U M b.com.
That's where you can get it.
It's called I'm no hero.
That's right.
And
also you can get some Jocko white tea on there.
If you need to drink liquid in your life,
you might as well drink a liquid that's going to make you smarter,
stronger,
faster,
and a more dynamic human being.
There was only one drink that does that and that's Jocko white tea.
By the way,
it's 147% double blind,
placebo approved and true and tested in a laboratory with people wearing white
outfits so you know or good to go weigh the warrior kid and this is the book
right there that's going to hit your kids from another angle and it is going to
get them to understand some things like hard work,
discipline,
honor,
physical training,
mental training,
studying.
No one thinks Jocko was going to write a book of teaching me how to study.
They didn't think that did that go tell me the truth.
They didn't think that.
No,
they didn't see my college grades.
So you learn how to study,
learn how to get stronger in the book where the Warrior kid get it for your kids
and you know what?
You're going to read it first and then you're going to get a copy for yourself
where the warrior kid get that.
Can I say something about one say apart?
Yeah,
sure.
We have another four hours of space on the recorder so let's do it.
There is a part when he sees small progress,
I think it was after one pull up and he's like,
yeah,
oh yeah,
fired up the part when he said he scolded him small,
mild scolding for celebrating too early or too much too early.
Jake says,
Hey,
take it easy,
they're good.
And,
but then he said,
no,
come over here.
Give me a high five and get back to work.
When you let them sell them in a little bit.
That was good man.
Jake is a good man.
It's good man.
He puts it out to it,
right?
Uh,
also you can preorder the book discipline Equals Freedom Field Manual,
which explains to you how to get after it.
So get after it and order the book.
Of course,
extreme ownership.
This is free leadership principles tested,
tested in combat testing in the business world.
They're there for you to read,
learn,
lead when and if you need more than that from the book.
If you need more than the book and the podcast for Your Business or your team.
Ashkelon Front Ashland,
font.com you can email@infointernationalonfront.com leadership and management
consulting training.
Also the muster number
three,
number three,
Austin,
Texas,
July 13th and 14th Omni Barton Creek resort.
I'm not going to say spot anymore.
Not going to the spa.
No,
I'm going to have that kind of shut down while we're there.
We know spa going on,
so come down July 13th and 14th at join us in the pursuit of world domination.
That's the goal and if you can't make Texas,
you can come to San Diego September 14th and 15th at back in SD for number four
and in the meantime,
while you're waiting for that,
if you have questions or comments for us,
you can get us on the interwebs.
Now,
first of all,
speaking of millennials,
Captain Plumb,
sir,
you are all up in the technology here.
You are on Twitter
at Captain Plumb,
right?
Right.
Facebook,
Facebook.
What's that at Linkedin,
same thing.
Captain Plumb,
just a social media junkie is what I'm hearing my kids keep me honest.
And,
and you also,
you mentioned quickly while we were talking that you do speaking engagements and
all that,
where's the best place to contact you for those type of events or consulting?
All on my website,
Charlie [inaudible] dot com it's all,
it's all there.
Awesome.
So,
and that's where they can find you as far as echo and myself,
we are also
cruising on the interwebs on Instagram,
on Twitter.
Echo is an echo.
Charles.
I am at Jocko Willink and we are also in the Facebook so you can check that one
as well.
Echo,
you got anything else for us today?
I don't.
Thank you so much then.
Surely and honor.
And Sir,
do you have anything,
any other closing thoughts you want to add?
Well I want to tell you about the rest of the story.
It says people might be interested in knowing that my ex wife married the guy
she was engaged to and there they'd been living happily for the last 43 years.
I
remarried a wonderful lady.
Yeah,
four kids,
two grandkids.
And one on the way.
My daughter is married to a marine and they're pregnant with her first child
should be doing in fact any day now.
Semper fi,
my daughter,
I have a wonderful wife that supports me and the puts up with me.
Uh,
and uh,
and,
and I'm,
I'm living the dream.
I really am.
I don't know how I could be happier in my life.
I could not write a story that would bring more fulfillment to me personally
then why already live?
I still fly airplanes.
I have two airplanes.
I have a home in a hanger as well.
My man cave.
And,
uh,
it's just,
it's,
it's a delight to be alive and I appreciate you for helping me tell my story
because,
uh,
I believe it's an important story now.
Not Everybody is going to be a prisoner of war.
In fact,
I hope,
I hope and pray none of the people listening to this podcast will ever be in
that eight foot cell that I was in.
But we all get into our own little prisons and,
and we can be,
I am convinced justice confined in our little eight inch box is I was in an
eight foot prison cell.
And so if,
if those challenges are the same,
then the solution is the same,
uh,
the solution to the prisons that we find ourselves in.
You know,
the self discipline that it takes,
the believing that yes,
I am in control of my,
my own life.
I am a captain of my soul and uh,
and that I do and I do make a difference.
So he put all those things together and um,
and you,
you can in fact live the life with the hand that you're dealt.
I won't even try and make any additional points on that other than to say when
you have a hangar with two planes in it for your man cave you when the man cave
contest.
Absolutely.
That's unbelievable.
And Sir,
obviously I,
I can't thank you enough for coming on the podcast for writing the book,
for sharing the knowledge that you paid so dearly to acquire and more important
than all of that.
I can't thank you enough for your service and your sacrifice
for six years
for us and for this great nation.
And you dedicate your book very simply
to the families of those brave men who will never return.
And for those families
and for those brave,
we will live.
And we will try to live as you have exemplified.
Okay.
With faith and pride and discipline
to overcome whatever hardships we might face and whatever obstacles might be in
our path.
Yeah.
And through those adversities,
discover every day
how to love this life.
So until next time,
this is captain Charlie plumb
an echo pen.
Jocko.
Oh.